You
setting up beforehand and I was adding the chat I was so confused because I'm
like why are people saying that straw knee rated I'm like oh maybe it's it's
grabbing stuff from a past tree but then they come into the chat you guys are
all here two hours I don't blame her I normally stream at four and she must
have been really tired cuz usually she'll message me and be like hey what
you doing so she must have been like knocked out
replaying continued puppy ring oh it's nice to see everybody yeah normally I
stream at four but I had some stuff to take care of beforehand grab more stuff
for Fia do some recording so busy busy and then sometimes I just like to move
around my schedule so it gives more time to relax and like clean my house and
vice versa cuz my house is an absolute mess right now still yeah I missed you
guys too I missed just playing games with you guys I was like gonna say I'm a
little low energy today as you can probably hear in my voice but I'm okay
I'm just low energy it's just been very tired I need to fix my sleep schedule
but don't worry I have some a gamer sops youth coach she be so I'll be ready to
rumble a little bit how was my day yesterday very very long I had a lot of
blood drawn at my doctor's appointment and my arm hurts so yeah you like the
voice message I'm glad I haven't so I normally don't listen to the finished
product but I listened to a part of it and I was like oh this sounds kind of
nice to be become talk to you she said she has some questions I did speak to my
sister she seemed a little flustered after the last stream she had with you
guys so yeah yes I am tan hello if you don't know me hi my name is she be caught
in bum and I am the girl failure Dom or I try to be indulge Gen 1 indulge from
the alert and I like to yap a lot I like to try on different outfits I like to
role play I like to voice act and I hope that you'll stay here a while yes
caught and bum I am she be caught in bum now I am tan as I mentioned on my
stream on my stream my Twitter I will be predominantly going forward using my
tan toggle not saying that flesh and blood she be will not be around but I
just prefer I think actually the model looks good with a little tan to be
honest with you so I think it's nice if it's the kind of Giardu aesthetic my
eyes let me give my little ooo mouth on yeah let's flash pay but I don't know but
it will take time to like change a lot of my stuff so I don't really like it'll
take I know like a year for that branding to stick so I'm not really a
verse to people drawing me pale pale skinned it doesn't really matter I am
very pale right now because I have not gone outside and I don't I honestly I
don't care either way but I want to predominantly stream as tan I know some
people might be a little bothered by that but I will I so a lot of people
wonder if I had input in the design before I started that I was too scared
to be tan that's not the case realistically it's very rare to see a
tan Corpo or agency vtuber the only other one I can think of besides Azera is
Serena although I know that there are more coming to the kind of the limelight
I've seen I think like two others pop up which I think is really cool but I had
no input I always I auditioned to an agency knowing I would probably be cast
like 99% sure be cast as someone who is pale or skinned and that never really
bothered me at all I am playing you know my the character and stuff and I
wasn't I probably just would have done handcams a lot less because people
sometimes like to speculate and such but I'm strong immediately when I was
hired was kind enough to say I'm so sorry I whitewashed you we're going to fix
this the summer bun is a beauty as thank you pookie but I it just made more sense
for me to be tan for immersion reasons and we're so early on we're set we're
only three months in so I think it's okay and most of you already knew that I
was tan anyways but yeah and sauna like sauna was such a pivotal person within
the hollow community it was a shame to see her go I wish someone like her was
still around but I appreciate you guys for being very understanding of the
change I will say first and foremost I will not I am a vtuber this is not like
some sort of political statement I just want to be myself because I find
myself growing closer and being one with she be every day at first I kind of went
into it like I'm going to play a character but I realize she's more
closer to me than I think I am she be and she beat is me
yeah the guy out and like that's it's interesting cuz tan really does fly
when it's guy out but you know yeah it's we're just hanging out but don't let
that distract you from my streams I also want to I feel like I haven't been
myself lately in terms of I've been pandering to a more how do you say
edgy or a crowd and that was not my intention I realize some people within
the community have taken jokes that I've said a little bit personally especially
when it comes to my skin tone and I never want anybody to be uncomfortable I do
make a joke here and there like because I'm black I can say that because I'm
black but I realize I don't really like what that perpetuates but I'm just
going to try to be a little bit more professional yes I have a lot of freedom
being an agency for being an agency vtuber however I feel like I have taken
that and have been a little bit I don't know I just feel like I've been kind of
someone that I'm not and I'm very I want to be an approachable and inviting
person I want people to yes I'm a Dom but I'm not you know a total bitch yeah I
just wanted to let you guys know that I will be because I you know I'm always
transparent and reflective with you so I just wanted to be honest that I will
stop making jokes like that and don't don't don't get it twisted this is not
like oh management told her to be like this oh people like oh no no nobody
told me to do anything I am my own woman I made this choice based off of realizing
I'm not an agency I'm not an indie vtuber I can't just say anything I am part of a
brand I'm part of a company and I want what's best for my gen mates and I will
put nothing of them in harm's way but yes yes I will just be me whatever
goats your float that's the thing I suppose but yeah so we're just gonna
have fun I'm also going to try to work a little bit harder at playing the Dom not
playing the Dom character because I'm one I'm realizing how much it is kind of
how I am I am I am a dominant woman if that makes any sense not in only like the
sexual sense but only like I see myself as I can be very motherly or older
sisterly and I want to be the best person for you all I just like I have my whip
out somewhere I forget where it went my whip is somewhere I like walk by it when
I was cleaning earlier and I was like why is this out yeah the ghiati Riz yeah I
also added a little I like the little mole I feel like I can't be a milfin only
have one mole but don't worry like I'm not like dramatically changing like my
design by the way guys like don't fear I don't think at like adding tan it
doesn't isn't that dramatic if I'm like actually I'm a cat girl now and I'm
going to be cute and funny and blah blah blah blah and I'm actually going to be a
sub blah blah then yes I would totally be pissed this is not what I signed up for
but no I'm not doing that of people are like are she rebranding as a nun I am
not that was just for fun role play there will be a nun in a future gen gen 4 you
heard it here first folks I'm telling you all the tea but yeah I thought it was
I'm very pleased that you guys liked the role play I think YouTube did too to be
honest with you because they at first I was limited but then I was I turned
green and I was like a man of God has reviewed this stream and they see that
it's as fit to be monetized not that it even matters I only get like ten dollars
whatever I can't be TV will also be yeah I will also be a part of gen 4 I am
leaving the first gen and coming back to that to the gen 4 I will graduate that
will come back you won't know it's me I have to ask since I'm a guy what are my
chances of becoming an agency Vtuber not really the stream for me to answer that
but I'll go ahead and answer this anyways very slim and I'll say that with
utmost honesty and transparency to you it's very difficult to become a male
agency Vtuber unless you join like hollow stars or like Nijisanji and that is very
competitive so good luck with that but I am not a dude I can't really speak on
that so I would ask male Vtubers as I am not male as you can tell by my
behunguzungus actually I think my I turned my physics down because of when I
put on like a booth outfit I have to turn my physics down there we go now you
guys can see me move a lot more and my mouth is an S stiff
she really bouncing a physique for the seven yeah that'll be me I'll be the
deep I it's so funny to me because I keep like the deep was in gossip girl and
you plays a totally different character and it's so funny to me I'm part of all
gents yes part of all gents because I watched worlds and hair what he wasn't
gossip yes he plays Nate in gossip girl he's a pivotal character watch gossip
girl gossip girl is one of my favorite shows they don't make shows like gossip
girl anymore she be in each gen I am going to groom the next gen so diligently
there'll be at least like two girls that will be like my children I'm I've been
like asking scrawny yeah he's Nate everybody's like what I I've been
asking scrawny like let me help with this let me help with this let me help
with this she's like you know what I'll give you a chance and then I helped her
with something issues like wait a second this is actually gold and I'm like oh
thank you very much mom please she's like we need you on the dev team I'm like I
will gladly allow me to I love character stuff guys it's my favorite my cat is
blocking my view my cat is this oh well that happens to me a lot so I
understand I'm going to yeah they're gonna call me madam instead of senpai no
but I'm so excited I always love making new friends always do my foster
children I hope so it'll be great yeah I don't know like I scrawny scrawny so
stressy she's just like oh who's gonna sign for Gen 2 and I'm like well you can
count on me like and I'm like you can count on all the girls to be honest with
you she she needs to give herself more credit is what I would say do they get
added to the family tree I don't think any of them are rabbits so probably not
she be able to do that if I wanted to pull an avial from idle then I would but
we see how that I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry any of them go ribbit no my
children are rabbits I don't my children are cats I have three children you know
one time I went to a psychic and she told me I would have three children and I
was just like one I'm single two I would not and you can make fun of me for
this I would not have children outside of wedlock all right I would not that is
haul it's the I don't know that's just me not people who do that I really care
but yeah then here are my three kids it's Raina boomy infium shoo shoo boo and
Shaba boomy for Gen 2 no no males no males at to at to is there something
behind the model oh wait a second you know what I just realized that this is
it this no there's something scrolling and I need to grab it it's not letting me
grab it oh maybe because it's locked nope that's me there we go I was looking
for that I'm like where'd that go
but practice making babies yeah I just practice with harem would you would you
the father of my babies and get married I told you like we've already had this
discussion like definitely gonna do some sort of marriage thing after a year we
have time to grow in our relationship together I'll say that much we're not
married yet did she say yep maybe maybe maybe you guys like I know that like
is the mom of Gen 1 and maybe we can partially like I can be partial mother
like surrogate mother of Gen 2 with the harem and then like us for reeflings
harem strongy and I can just like have birthed Gen 2 together although I don't
really have much say in Gen 2 but you know I try I can be the god mother two
moms or I grow a food food a fushigi I grow a fushigi and I help strongy grow
large with planting seeds and fields and then maybe she and she and then yeah yeah
you guys you guys know what I'm you guys know yeah you know grow large finally
giant is content you have you have a zero for that as there is a giant as people
forget so strong he is not the no I'm the dad you kidding me I'm the I wear the
pants in this relationship I want on an art of that on on the double I'm already
picturing it and it looks in my head it looks very nice I madam where's the
slacks precisely I wear the pants I am the type of person and I've said this
story before I've gone out to eat with Salem and Olive and or and no it was
just all of and they got all of order wrong and I went and I turned to the
waitress and I was like excuse me she did not order that and she was just like
she be no it's okay and I'm like she did not order this she's allergic you could
kill her chat's broken it's fine this happens often when I use this I don't
know why if I refresh the cash maybe though it does that every so often it
will not catch up I might just turn it off I might just turn off the um the
chopped she asked for no pickles yeah it doesn't want to work you're just gonna
have yourselves just staring with those faces
strani said the reeflings of the dad I've done one and two but strani also gave
birth to us so it's a little bit of a mess well I well strani can be like a cat
or a snake and have multiple fathers for multiple children did you know that
did you know that snakes and cats can do that I forget what else it's like a
it's like a it's an evolutionary thing where like a snake can retain the the
ink of a of a former suitor and ink themselves
called her daughter well don't worry about that we have Emmy for a reason
without it look at her stick you Charlie for the five super so what I'm hearing is
that she was gonna steal strani away from us no no no it'll only be for your
amusement this is a group activity they're printers now I guess and yeah
cats cats have it like a cat can dance with multiple partners and then all the
kids can have multiple like it's very interesting because they remember like
cats are individual in their own little sack so I am yep that's true I I speak
for the reeflings I speak for them cat Marry should be wild booby listening
boobies knocked out he's like asleep on the cat tree and Fia sleeping on the
couch and then Reina is staring at me because I know she's gonna come over
here in a second thank you for the soup I again Charlie I hope it goes well
theoretically if that humans could do that what did it make it so that probably
I see you love doing on ASMR also that was a great scotter's impersonation thank
you I try my best I'm trying to work on it's a lot better I said to listen to
strani more but then it kind of sounds Irish oh hi Reina it was very funny that
people pointed thought it was very funny that I was able to like when I never
broke like the accent when I like when like Reina and boomie were like breaking
things around me Reina mentioned yes Reina is actually standing in front of
me on my desk right now wondering why I have not picked her up yet there you go
lady please don't sit on my headphones there you go Fia is doing well too she's
doing fine she's getting stronger every day I have a appointment with the doctor
for her in a couple weeks and she should be very much more healed by then she's
very funny because I have to like the syringe feeder like bottle feed her so
she's like a little baby I've been using like little little like my dish cloths as
her bib and she she's she does great she can bench she can bench your mother and
that's a feature to itself what else yeah she like kicked out her foot she's been
pretty talkative however I live in like feeding her me relax cuz I'm trying to
get her to poop cuz like when her when she's like this it's like again her
muscles aren't working so it's like it's like she can't like push stuff out so
trying to help her poop but she doesn't poop oh this is a perfect timing thank you
thank you average amphibian for the five gifted oh no brother I don't think
you're ever getting a gifted I'm so sorry but she's doing better don't worry
she's very she's she's in high spirits I gave her a fishy and she was crunching
on it and I was impressed because before she couldn't like chew that well but now
she can she be love oh thank you Coyote Briggs thank you um but yeah we're gonna
play some Hades today I've been missing Hades I don't even remember how to play
anymore so this will be fun cuz I don't I'm gonna mess everything up I wish there
was a play for me to like like save scum I had a bunny who poopy issues oh yeah
that's too bad me when I have ice cream hope my gift arrives soon helps with
the cleaning yeah I like thank you for that gift by the way you guys have been
so good to me with the gifts I every time it's it's a major help cuz all of my
stuff goes to like all of my revenue stuff goes to like bills and stuff and
then like I portion like stuff for like food and then but like anytime I like
need something like something practical I usually put it up on throne and you
guys always get it for me so thank you for taking care of me your mirror is the
most important asset of the game true oh no I feel like I've been here longer
thank you thank you for the one moment it's okay it's it's funny like there's a
sense of like we've always been together it's very interesting to me I feel like
what's it called I feel like I've been streaming like this and she be for such
a long time I don't know why it's not catching up I'm just gonna turn it off
no over no no chatting for anyone how about that actually
excuse me bleeding reef links and pie for the most vocally talented and be a
lawyer different characters make me laugh I would not say I'm the most vocally
talented I would not say that but thank you I would say that would be in me for
her to maintain her voice for hours and she streams with you guys
no chat she hates us well do you want to see like I just keep freezing the
entire time I don't know what to tell you it's not even showing up anymore oh I
think it actually caught up yeah let's go vocal talent contest I know Strani
wants to do some sort of contest are we back bros are we back yeah I don't think
I could maintain boomers lawyer tipped $6.90 after looking over the footage the
other day the actions of my client with the direct result of the crimes rena
committed in court the results of boomy a bystander fleeing a crime perpetrated by
rena she is fault for any damage caused by boomy okay your honor your honor may I
approach the bench thank you my client the entirety no my clients rena and fia
would beg to differ boomy did not have to react such a way as rena did not react
such a way at all when she accidentally knocked over something she knocked over
my iPad and she sat there nicely and looked at me apologetically whereas boomy
decided to throw himself against the desk and knock a bazillion things off of it run
pelt pelt around my house in circles fly into the wall and then yes I will have to deny that is
all I say I rest my case thank you for the don't objection I've never played Phoenix right
I've seen gameplay but I've never played it myself I think that would be fun because
I think the voice acting would be fun like I want to do there's a couple of like
sort of visual novels I want to play so
I just give Phoenix like this stupidest voice your honor I was like
I would say that this person is wrong objection and then like I just gave a really snooty
British voice to the other guy I'd be like watch you in this room at this place at this time
yeah rain and chill animal boomy is on x-game mode yeah we don't we don't need that
we don't need that Phoenix right because
ow I just hit my knee
hold on I want to make sure I could see fia for my chair
you sound like someone who smoked too much so that dude oh aren't you funny boomer's lawyer
took four dollars and 20 cents objection your honor boomy is a young frightened boy
emotionally scarred by she be cotton boy showing his pouch without his consent to his plan it's
sat to sit what is it called
I don't know what those things are called when I walked away what happened
objection your honor boomy is a young frightened boy emotionally scarred by she be cotton boy
I'm showing his pouch without his consent to her followers your honor your honor your honor
irrelevance irrelevance he is
irrelevance how does this pertain to the case that boomy is a menace I may have showed his pouch
but it was recompense for his crimes exploit it is not my fault he has such a uh large
you know actually I'll be honest with you boobies like that like I've noticed he's very um skittish
now ever since the bazillion fire alarms that used to go off in my apartment because of my stupid
neighbors my apartment building which is a bummer because I know he wouldn't be a skittish
if those things didn't happen and I'm like how do I sue my apartment for emotionally damaging my son
and making him have terrible anxiety like I had to get him like calming catnip and like I'll give
him like a piece of gabba peton gabba peton is a pain medication or for nerves but you can also
use it to sedate a cat um so I'll give him like a small quantity just so he can chill out I feel
so bad emotional damage yeah it stinks like oh there's a floating object behind me
oh I think I know what it is hold on I think it's the veil from the nun outfit it is
nope that's my mole
I didn't mean to grab my mole there it is
it's my bridal veil we're getting married surprised are you surprised isn't this what you wanted
I didn't see it so I didn't believe you I'm sorry I should have never doubted you
I apologize
boomie will get therapy from the winnings honestly I should send them to a cat therapist
I'm not no it's in the I'm not wearing the dress I'm just wearing the veil my sweets
girl failure to girl wife no that that came out wrong uh
uh to girl failure to wife failure that is what I meant to say I'm so sorry no
oh hey whistle oh there's a save slot take a girl out to dinner first won't you
Reina's lawyer tipped $6.90 your honor boomie has a long history of menacing behavior
much of which has been captured in plain day on stream true the latest incident was not his first
and surely will not be his last it will not the trial will continue I I might have to do a
whole role play on this Reina's lawyer ASMR you get taken to court
Reina has a lawyer girl failure to girl failure what can I say the case never ends
wait who's the jury the jury's you guys you're the jury
court draw my eyes I have to out the study for that
I'm like are there any lawyer vtubers that are female because then I would get them on
if anyone should have a lawyer should be fia to be honest he's boomie and fia uh and Reina
like just sit on fia if I like put her in the cat tree where they all like to hang out
they'll just sit on her and I'm like and she's like and I'm like she's literally just like
she's paralyzed you guys can't just crush her with your weight oh mercy you should represent fia
my mold looks it's a bug near my eye hold on I can fix that it's because it's pinned to my hair
for some reason that looks so funny my mole has a mind of its own
wait is there another one oh no I have just like something on my screen
what I do is I attach it to my blush and then it usually doesn't move
because right now it's not attached to my blush
yeah there we go so now it's actually like on my cheek when I talk and blink
or maybe I'm just gonna be a woman of many moles I can just put it down here like here
very Marilyn Monroe
it just looks like I have schmutz on my face though I can do a little uh
I was going to do a little um
tome moment
I could do a little like I'm your mother yes me
I could put it on this and I'm just gonna stick it on the middle of my head
why isn't my mouth opening hello I don't know what's up with my mouth tracking lately
I'm sorry I just think of like that screen you guys have probably seen like the screenshot of like
doki's uh model just like and that that one clip but she's like
like
by the way someone screenshot me using that
yeah that was a that was a funny funny clip
oh this is your shot he shot he shot indeed
all right I'm probably gonna die because I haven't played this game in a while
okay uh madame cotton bum you live right free in my head and I'm thankful for every second of it
keep up the good work gorgeous I'll stop it you thank you Gregory Gregory sorry just think of
just think of um
five nights of parties
guys that's what it takes to have a whole yeah I just felt just get a little like get a little
bit of makeup and just dab it there it'll be fine your honor we have the we the jury have
discovered that boomy is also wanted for tax evasion and destruction of property we move
to prosecute boomy for his crimes
I can't believe enough has been out for 10 years I remember
like I don't know if that'll show my age coming after school and sitting and watching Markiplier
haha anyways um
does this cost anything to restore
all right
can wash away my boons
oh I can I can sacrifice my boons in exchange that's right um
none other than those in the trusted inner circle of lord hades are authorized to enter
the intricate chambers connecting the vast regions of the underworld but the prince decides to barge in
any way Homer or whoever this is I barred where I please I barred where I please
heck maxi
I remember coming after school sitting and watching Pewdiepie play amnesia
back good I want to play I think I have amnesia dark descent I want to do um
a heart rate monitor for that possibly shock collar alongside
a lot of d a lot of dog
oh
now we're getting somewhere I'm scared Ashful Dell
do I have to fight people because I can't remember please like get me grace
the once verdant planes of asphodel are now engulfed in scintillating flame
scintillating flame by the river flagathon flagathon that's what they call me in high school
could bring death swiftly even to those resistant because I was hot as fuck sorry
I'm only flame resistant but flame proof oh you think he'd be flamers you think him and
Hades would be flame-resistant her stage is safe I used to come with the school
mark play subnautica yeah I can't what place I'm not like subnautica is a true horror game for me
because I'm terrified of deep water like I'll go to the ocean but I'll be like hugging the freaking
shore you bet your bottom dollar oh this place is definitely seeing better days
I think it looks nice lava you know
trying to make more space on my desk my desk feels a little bit small
my controller am I using I am using my playstation 5 controller
I'm okay
oh freaking for off on my beloved
oh and then I believe this is my chuck thing
how the hell am I supposed to get that back
are you kidding me oh oh what I can walk over that
huh
all righty I didn't expect that
that's my shoulder
I know I'm hurting myself I noticed this I was just checking I didn't know I could walk on lava like
like Hades Jesus
no I'm I'm trying not to I'm trying not to I'm literally oh I just have to click and bark
oh I didn't know that was a bow
well
uh we're probably not going very far boys slam dancers
what is that I'm already gonna die
uh the dash what's the dash
oh
okay they're also affected by water I mean water lava hello
ah I didn't mean to throw that
oh
ouchy mama
am I supposed to like move forward
I'm kind of like hurting real bad and I'd rather not
oh I wish I could jump oh no
no
I should keep going I would love to except I have 12 health so like what about that
lava is just spicy water it's really hard like the lava looks so nice I just want to like step
it like I like I just want to eat lava like I also like melted glass and stuff too you know like
it looks so delicious you can dash over the lava oh
yeah real rusty
I kind of want health I would prefer health than these two things
moving on
I'm so mad that I'm gonna probably have to go all the way back and do this all over again
I have to fight Meg
um what the sigma
I think he's in boom rakers
I feel like I had more boobs I don't I feel like something's going on here
oh
how did I do 14 damage to me
I thought I would have had where's my
did it just totally disregard my talisman thing back again
don't let you eat rockados
wasabi makes my nose run I died before oh I thought because I like went to the next level
that I would have I would have reset all right any wiser yet whatever dad
oh I can switch keepsakes
interested
I know it is it is pretty much a very identical map so it's not like the whole dungeon shifts
I can get luxurious sheet seating um yeah I'll do that
uh
they don't have any other money I'm here by authorizing this expenditure
and I look forward to seeing the result
mom I mean kind of not my mom the mirror in your bed chamber has proved satisfactory dear child
yeah better than I could have possibly imagined next you mentioned there was something more that
it could do once I had grandma accustomed I think I'm ready for that now I'm ready I think you are
as well then it shall be as you wish sounds like sometimes she's talking about sin can like
she's talking like she's really far away new talents available hey who are you oh mech
everyone's saying I went easy I love her voice so much I want to be just like her
imagine imagine my outfit her outfit on me
the prodigal sun returns everyone's saying I went easy on you Zach
I think I want to be her I think I'm gonna start looking up to Meg I think Meg is gonna
be my role model what do you think
I don't worry Meg I eventually managed to get home the painful way after dying
look I have a reputation to uphold she's very likely like that you best go all the way
now leave me be and don't think you're gonna be so lucky next to her she does sound like that Meg
and material look I have a reputation to I can't do it though wait could you say that again
can I talk to you again can I no all right I wanted to hear your voices a little more
damn sad damn daddy what's going on here on your desk
second Tartarus all because he stops gays on a whore daughter
you think Meg pegs a hundred percent
my desk is far more organized than you boy and if you're also concerned about our court
musician why don't you commute to sentence yourself seeing as I haven't gotten around to it yet
I have a court musician sure happy to oblige I'll just
contractor mind locating the court musician sentence when you get the court musician
who oh what do you have to say what do you I just remember I don't like you
quiet keeping watch over the pool of sticks back there but it's sure been busy lately
why somebody else came through just earlier interesting to look on my face when it wasn't
you who was it plan to keep things interesting who was it
like how there's like ghost furniture oh no I thought these were chairs like what's up these
ghost seats music man
calls it megging wait I guess Achilles
where did you go can I look over here no
can I go over here still locked
I could just totally like steal that
so I was I've been like binge watching The Last Kingdom and it's been pretty good I've been on
like some sort of Vikings kick but I was tired of watching Valhalla Vikings Valhalla because it's
not as good as you know the original Viking series and um I'm like just watching like you know
all these people are dying there's war whatever you're about your business and I'm like guy like
why does nobody like take money from their pockets like there's like plenty of free armor
you got plenty of like iron you can make I'll take that remember to use the mirror yeah I know
you're not my dad yeah I miss the original Vikings was great um oh she's sparkling
reflect the mirror has grown in power thank you nicks
sick
all right and then I'll start saving for that one
I still don't have enough keys for this yet I need more catholic keys for this I need more catholic
keys for this I've been sitting on my acia toy a toy but I haven't looked at this sooner and I've
probably been around for centuries my time is different for gods hello hey skelly you look like
you know your way around Tartarus found some of this ancient titan blood out there and I was looking
to score some more notice the icon on the left you can change it to another buff what do you mean
on the mirror I've come to the right place regarding that there pal it's your mean weapons back there
can find the stuff once you get all the way through Tartarus with one that's all the blood
you're gonna get for the time being anyhow what a time being how am I wondering what the accent is
I don't know there's always the invention of writing stuff down you'll figure something out
get absolutely just wrecked okay what are you talking about
what do you be the bottom quarter
oh it can reset the town
I don't know the left
I'm oh wait I'm looking at the oh
what the heck
I wasn't looking at those icons
maybe like so why would I
oh one time per chamber
so I could die in a chamber and just get it back
yeah they need a more like they need like exclamation points on those things
you think death deviance is definitely better than stubborn I don't know if this is per chamber
it's only 20% less
oh so I don't have to pick it up I can just it just takes five seconds to come back to me I would
actually prefer that
yeah yeah fascinating fascinating
yeah but I don't know if I'm gonna run into any boss oh I don't know if this run I felt just like
sprint towards whomever
yeah that's true bosses will kill you twice that's a good point that's a good point
all right I think I'll stick with that and we'll see I got a toot
can't tell if I have to pee
I think I got a pee I'll be right back
oh sure it'll take me five seconds everyone
okay
boomi always insists joining me
like he's gonna guard me
wait what what's with those random 99 cents what what's happening what are these supas
thank you raya thank you sirey
what's going on boomi wants to watch
it's the p-tax
no boomi's like if I leave a room he like has to be in the room with me so he'll follow me
like he was literally just dead asleep but he heard me get up and so he just followed me
and just sits scattered why are you scattering it's just to relate to the toilet
what boomi guard but like yeah isn't that like a factual thing like sometimes your pets will
like join you in the bathroom because they know it's when you're most vulnerable is when you're
using it
making sure she really has a life card this isn't the beach this is a bathtub
don't piss girl but thank you for the supas
my pet why would you have a pet lobster handed over i'm eating it
velcro pets are just sweeties he's not even like a velcro pet like he doesn't like sit on my lap
or anything he won't doesn't want to snuggle he'll just he just wants to be near and receive head
much like myself clingy but in a different fashion in a different sense
didn't the last lobster mess you up it did oh my god i like i love seafood but lately i've been
striking out you want to let someone eat your cats well that's a good point i would not let
somebody eat my cats but i don't know how you can form an emotional bond with a lobster
but you do you boo i won't knock it
um oh yeah you guys told me the claws are nice i'm gonna unlock those yet i will continue to
use but varatha my my beloved i like how they haven't like boarded up this wall
wow another day in tartarus all night i have no idea yeah i have the lucky two
who what are these little like locked parts oh a secret stash okay
excuse me i need a snack but i don't have any snacks i might have to go grocery shopping again
you like the sword for alie he makes sense again
no boomi doesn't come on my my desk to snuggle
you can shake the earth up there all he pleases he just comes to sit and watch
okay we gods are all alike why are you just like hating on your brother randomly
all right artemus what do you got for me girly pop
hey that's the eternal spear varatha isn't it your father used to use that didn't he
a bit on eight for hunting but a spear's a spear is what i like to say
i'll do that one okay remember how to freaking wow
i hate that i'm back here
it's stupid in it
let's be reasonable though
oh i remember you freaking jump for the bar
these i can stun lock them
okay tracking
kind of
sick
yeah yeah i know dying is part of the game but i'm a very i don't care about artemus
please give me some better booms artemus i'm sorry
okay
that's where i would really like the multiple hits
all right again
is it only the critical chance
two percent more
i'll do the true shot
yes i recall the big spin
hey oh it just takes too long in my opinion the animation
nope it's not that one that alley how did that kill him so fast but the other ones didn't
i just like to throw crap it's fun it's like i can use it oh no no
oh i suppose let's try it yeah see this doesn't work so well animation's too long
treating it like it's a freaking souls game
someone's going to enjoy this okay i suppose that's fine
oh i can go to the chaos land
yeah that's why i like the range
all these freaking lasers i hate that they do one
i hate that so much
somebody got this astrology girlies crap away
good come on in
no don't come on in which one's the police first
ah i forget that i could dash
these are easier let's try it
how are you hitting me
time to mix up my style
i like the triple job
however
but i barely use a spin
so
ooh ramen sounds good why am i so small it's because i'm leaning away from my computer
let me make myself a little bit bigger
yeah way off
you can pre-charge it yeah but you do you think i'm that smart i'm not
there's all the firepower i can get
oh i'm gonna keep
oh oh dash out please
oh
why aren't you dead
yeah that's the fight
oh this is so stupid i'm not getting this is not a good run
i don't like that that can go
oh that's in the shoppy bop
only for six encounters though
one time benefit i'm kind of tempted to do this
because i just feel like this is not like
oh yes highly recommend playing this game
i'm gonna do the fateful twist
i don't know what that does but it's fine
what does the prometheus stone do we'll never know
oh aphrodite girly pop
........ oh i'm gonna die
Did I give her a, did I already give her a gift?
I think I did.
Oh, that's adorable.
I might do some jazz.
However...
Oh, this is epic though.
Oh, that's what happened to us.
It's beautiful.
Can I boo me?
Spam it.
Spam it! Spam it before you come closer!
I just like that thing a lot.
Get over here!
Yeah, why don't you guys step on one of those buttons?
Ow.
Don't hurt me!
I'm just a pretty boy.
You wouldn't hurt a pretty boy like me.
I'm too pretty to be hurt with my weak...
I wish I could have this.
Oh.
Vitality.
Uh, Kathoniki.
Oh, what's that?
I don't really care about that.
For the trove trial.
Yeah, okay.
She's a boy. What do you mean?
I like how I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, it's going to break, I'm telling you.
Oh.
Okay, this definitely doesn't do what I wanted.
It's not, it's like very delayed.
Why'd she spawn right behind me, bro?
That's not nice.
Get sniped, get sniped.
What else is here?
How am I not done yet?
There we go.
Let's go chat with Dionysus.
Kami Brochie.
I am the best Brochie.
Shabros-
Shabroski in the chat.
Got scared by an egg.
I'm chucking.
I'm throwing.
Literally, I'm just throwing this game.
How'd that not kill it?
Jams.
Shoot your little lasers at me.
My eye is itchy.
What I like about this game is that I can just press buttons
and I don't have to worry about like,
oh, I have to move in this, or that direction.
Who is throwing these?
Is it you?
You little bitch.
How are you not dead?
Oh, I should probably get out of the way.
Get out of the way, Dionysus.
How is this locked?
I don't have enough money.
Oh, this is not Dionysus.
I'm so stupid.
I haven't even been using my cast.
Because I would prefer to have something.
Because I've been spamming my-
Powered up.
That one and I might as well do this.
Ow.
Sold.
For the highest bidder.
Sorry about that.
Sorry I'm looking around.
But I haven't been using my cast.
Oh my god.
Well, they have that choke point.
I don't know what to do about that.
I can't run through that.
I don't even know if I can dash through that.
Oh my god.
Jeez.
I'd rather get that.
Okay.
I don't know what to do about that.
I'd rather get that.
Okay.
Can I please get some nice boons?
It really wants me to upgrade my cast.
It'll come in handy when I actually get a boon for it.
Oh, I forgot that you did.
Thank you.
I thought you would be...
I don't know what to do about that.
I don't want a different dash.
Oh my god.
Why is there something in here?
Ow.
I hate this so much.
You're like, I hate this game.
Right there.
I don't like the way she do it.
They just really don't want me to run to any gods besides the ones that do buffs for things that I just...
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, I'll start using my freaking cast.
Yeah, yeah, I think because of the...
What the heck?
I love you so much.
You are so hot.
I love your voice.
Oh my...
I wish I talked like that naturally.
The result wasn't like...
You were like...
It's not a matter of want.
The way out is there, in that direction.
You're more stubborn than your father.
I already got my justified thing.
I just kind of want you to kill me again.
I'm pervious.
Aren't you?
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck on pause.
You're dumb.
Oh, I thought I might...
Okay.
Oh, I forgot.
I have another death defy because I was lucky too.
You're numb?
I need to back up now.
Back up?
Okay.
Help.
You are...
I already got my first tier.
I'm stuck.
Oh, I'm freaking out.
I hate those.
All right.
How did this take me so many tries?
My first run.
Does she weaken?
After you get to Asphodel?
Because like, what the hell was that?
What the hell was that?
I haven't touched this game in like two weeks!
Oh, my dash put weaken on her.
Oh, I guess that was helpful.
God damn.
She got shy.
You're going nowhere, boy.
Dad, you're making my screen red.
Okay, so that allows me to...
...
Worth it.
You can sell some.
I'm good, actually, on that.
Uh, all right.
Yeah!
I don't know how I beat the Dancing Lion so fast.
Thank you, Mimic Tier.
Did he get stronger points but into the Darkness Mirror bathrooms?
Okay.
Oh, I can change it since I used my Death Default.
That's a good point.
I'm like, can I like take it off and put it back on?
Okay.
I might just take a black shawl for now.
I was thinking about that.
I usually run into stuff.
Switch to Tooth After Meg.
That's a good point.
Yeah, I'm thinking.
I'm thinking.
Hold on.
Oh.
Did I click the right one?
Okay, I did.
I thought I accidentally selected something else.
I was supposed to be like, wait, what?
Okay.
Lovely.
May all wins be baddie in your deaths, few.
Thank you.
I feel like someone should be here, like to talk to you for some reason.
Oh, I get coins, my first thing.
That's stupid.
Stupid in it.
Hello.
Oh.
Come on, dances.
I'm trying to like weaken them.
It's hard now.
I'm using my cast.
Oh, what the?
Interesting.
Welcome.
I look at the other guys over there.
Hi, you fool.
Oh my God.
I need a stronger main attack.
Nice.
Hermes.
Interesante.
Oh, or I can get health.
You know, I'm actually going to go to Hermes.
It's palms for my special.
I think maybe the souls game did make me better.
I like, it's funny because I like range stuff.
Ow, ow.
But it's like, if I play a soul book, book, book, book, book,
if I play a soul's like,
damn, damn.
It's Hermes.
Um, I'll give something.
Did I already gift Hermes?
I don't think I did.
Lord Hermes, please accept this gift as a...
Hello, Hermes.
I'm mighty keen of you to be the tip there, boss.
And I have a tip for you.
Don't be slow.
New cast is going to be your damage to the target.
I don't know.
You think I pay attention?
I leveled up my reaction time.
Yes, the Hermes is very lovely.
I like how it's...
The chat just really eases.
I don't know why it eases.
Can I open it?
Because it's, it's like a little widget thing you can use.
YouTube chat overload.
It's like pages.
I got a tube.
Did that mute?
I don't think it did.
I don't think so.
Because I saw my...
The base covered it?
Good.
Because I, I pressed the mute...
The base goes hard, it does.
But, uh, I realize...
It looks like it, like, like it...
The green bar from, like, my mic goes down,
but I'm like, does that mean I'm still unmuted?
Wait, wait.
Okay.
Can you guys hear me when I do this?
Did you hear what I said?
Did you hear?
You hear what I said?
No?
Okay.
So you got, yeah, you guys, okay.
I just said hi, don't worry about it.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh, you gave me one health.
Lambient plume.
What's going on there, cause?
Not like, cause.
Like, cause.
You talk fast.
My God.
Chance of dodge.
I can dash more.
I don't know if I should get greater evasion or...
I haven't been using my cast too much.
It hasn't really been a focus.
But I've been needing to dash more.
I think I might do the dash.
Yeah.
Especially because I'm over here.
Prophecy foretold.
What else could I choose from?
Oh!
A little double boonage.
I can do that.
I can do some double boonage.
You want the game volume back up?
Hold on.
Oh.
Heller.
Oh!
Why won't they be...
Well, I'm going with effort ID.
I'm gonna get that, cause I want to be straight.
Listen!
I thought it was gonna be the both of you.
Forgive me, Lady Artemis.
Listen.
I didn't know that she was like that.
Oh, I'm happy I got this.
The dash.
What the hell?
Oh my god!
What the...
What is happening?
Oh god.
Oh my.
I'm very happy I got the dash.
Oh.
Hello.
Oh!
You make me mad.
I'll hunt you like a stag.
You heard of those.
Did she?
What?
Damn!
Artemis just rocked me cause I need a picker.
Hey, Hypnos.
That's a good one.
You know I can't let you enter your death.
Oh, it's my dad's chambers?
Nothing from you back there anyway.
It's a full attempt.
Hi puppy.
You don't like it when I pet your other heads, huh?
No.
That's exactly how boomy is.
He just like does the same exact thing.
I can talk to my dog.
Hey boy, just me again.
Need to report it's pretty dangerous out there.
Even without you on guard duty all the time.
Are you just telling him he's not doing a good job?
The sound of hell bear late knowledge is the softly spoken princess platitude.
Knowing full well the underworld is not as vision.
He calls all yonderes.
Giving nectar to Hypnos.
Maybe that's why they make him an ass.
Hello.
Because I never want to give him a nectar.
You're back.
Oh, hey.
Achilles, sir.
I got a relic of some sort out there.
A club you will have ancient blood which formed after I fought with Megara.
Is this really the Titan's blood I found?
Yeah, that's really weird.
As far as I know.
Yes, lad.
That it is.
Though who's exactly I'm not so sure.
You best hang on to it.
Interesting.
I wasn't about to drink it.
Why can't I drink it?
I want to drink the Titan's blood.
Oh, that's so sparkly when I run around.
Are my feet on?
I haven't noticed that my feet are on fire.
Was that always a thing?
Was my feet always on fire?
Achilles is now the employee of the month.
Oh, my sweet Dusa.
Come back, Dusa.
I want to romance you, Dusa.
Please.
I got my burning feet from my paw.
Looks like I'm just wearing socks that are on fire.
Okay, that's Max.
I just want to see.
Okay, I kind of had it.
Dang.
How much is it if I get 500?
What do I spend my money on?
500 plus it's a 2?
Oh, I...
Had a head.
I think I might get dark regeneration.
Firey presence.
Can I unlock this?
How many keys do I got?
I live two.
I thought I had like four with the house.
Yeah, yeah.
You're telling me things I've like definitely known for a while.
I was like stuck behind there for a second.
I'm going to try to do it without the tooth.
Yeah, let's try it.
Please give me someone good.
That's fine.
I always prefer Poseidon.
Yes, I love Maratha.
What do you have for me?
Chain lightning.
I like chain lightning.
I'm going to do the electric shot.
All right, no tooths.
Yeah.
Doesn't that change it?
I like that.
Where did it go?
Looks like I will not get it back.
Oh, that's right.
It takes five seconds to do it now.
I was thinking I had to retrieve it.
That's nice actually.
Because then it just takes me five seconds to wait for the cast to come back.
Which is pretty cool.
There's something spawned behind me.
Yeah, that's pretty nifty.
I don't...
Oh, that's actually nice.
Cool.
I wish you would give me a boon, but that's fine.
I'm the wrong soul.
What the hell?
Oh, I'm not paying attention.
Sorry, I'm reading chat.
Electric slide.
Wow.
What are you guys hiding in there for?
Oh, no.
I can die.
I mean, I didn't get it.
All right, give me a boon.
No, we're not.
I could go to Chaos Land.
Honestly, the temptation's there.
I want to give like a nectar to Chaos.
That'd be funny.
Okay, you know what?
Let's do it.
I have the health for it.
Let me have it.
Darkness.
Oh, darkness.
This is like one of my favorite designs I've ever seen in my life.
It's very cool that they react to what you're holding.
I think that's nice.
Lex, you're kind of your dash.
Oh, I don't care about getting money.
That's fine.
72% more foes to be rare about.
Oh, that's fine.
Two and three are nice.
Fascinating.
Fascinating indeed.
I think I'll go with three.
Oh, son of babies.
Oh, and then you let me pick where I want to go.
That's pretty sick, actually.
I kind of want keys though.
So I can unlock more stuff.
Oh, oh, oh my.
Oh, can you?
It's a show.
I don't recall you guys being able to throw that much.
That's right.
All right, what do you got for me?
Oh, come on, please.
Blaze.
I just want good foods.
Oh, you guys are so freaking annoying.
I think I can, like, break them.
But, like, sometimes I can't always hit them like that.
If I stand right in front of them, I'm fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, hey.
Hey, mama.
Hey, upper diney.
What's up, clean?
You and me.
You're boneless.
Oh.
I don't have a lot of good stuff.
Thanks.
You're dashed.
I don't want to be dead.
I mean, all right, I just want someone to move.
Because I don't get my higher attack until...
Oh, god.
I go through three rooms, so I'm sorry.
Oh, goodness.
You're killing me.
No, at least you're stumblobs now.
Oh, that took too long.
There, at least you're stumblobs.
That's cute.
I might be closer to you, actually.
There we go.
You were all related.
You're literally like my cousin.
Bye-bye.
Thank you for stopping by.
She's not wearing any clothes.
She's no outfit.
Imagine?
She being after daddy's outfit to super long hair.
She's just learning to stun tech.
I'm going to take this epic.
I need a good dash.
I need a good dash desperately.
Poseidon, baby boy, where are you?
Where are you?
Grease the original, Obama.
Oh, my.
I didn't see you there.
Fast.
Yeah.
Ha-ha, bitch.
All right.
Okay, Zeus, give me some lightning sprint, please.
Oh, I thought I was going to fall down there for some reason.
Stay out of range.
Sick.
In the name of Hades.
What's up, Zeus?
Thunderdash.
Oh, but my attack.
Oh, virtual damage.
Oh, frick.
I don't know which one to pick.
Yeah, the static discharge sounds good.
Because I would...
victims this.
Yeah.
That's good for crowd control.
Oh, yeah.
I'll do static discharge.
Hopefully we get another boon.
Oh, perfect.
Oh, shh.
Okay, we're going to do the hammer because it will help.
Although I normally would love to talk to Aphrodite.
How do they miss you?
How do they...
How can they throw these so far is my question?
Ow.
That is my question.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
I love the chain.
The chain is my favorite.
Is there like...
Can I have, like, some health, please?
Is there any, like, trial that I could do?
I said chains, not trains.
You sick bastards.
Like, that's great.
Oh, what?
Why did you spawn in the same spot?
Chain.
I'm close to death chain.
Oh.
I love it.
Like, like, look at this.
Look at that.
It's great for these dudes.
What?
Oh.
I'm like, hello?
Can I grab the key?
Ever get...
This is...
Who is this again?
Is this, um, Sisyphus?
Is that Sisyphus' symbol?
Okay.
I'll go see Sisyphus.
Hey!
It's...
I would take you with me, to be honest.
You go through a lot.
I forget what you even did.
I was a fire-stepping youngster.
Yeah, cause he'll give me more healing.
Easy does it.
Yeah, cause that would have only given me, like,
a little bit of healing.
Yeah, that's fine.
I can talk to a bouldie?
I can't...
What do you talk about?
I can't talk to the boulder?
Cause the ghost was like,
Talk to his friend?
What friend?
I can't talk to him.
I'm not trying hard enough?
Why does it have a face, actually?
That's a little disconcerting.
Cool.
Any of you good enough friends with Sisyphus?
Alright, maybe if I give him...
I don't think I give...
No, I did give him a...
a nectar, so I'm surprised you can't talk to him.
Bye!
Bye, Sisyphus!
Oh!
I don't have any money.
I'll take this, though.
Hi, what's going on?
If there happens to be something really horrible
awaiting me beyond that door, then...
I like how Karen's just, like, this wacky-looking spirit.
He's done an all-chaos run?
Oh.
Hi, Meg.
Hi.
Listen to me, Zacharias.
Your mother is long gone.
Why do you have to be a bitch about that?
You're kind of rude for that.
Yeah, it's not your business, lady.
Like, ah, you're hot and all,
but you can't talk about my mom that way.
I don't think I'm going to be able to get her this time,
because I don't have a week.
And I'm a lot.
I don't have the Depthify.
I don't have the extra Sprint either.
Oh, yeah, let's just turn this off.
Ow!
I don't know.
Oh!
Spam, let's grab it.
Just a geiger.
I'm trying to get him here.
Ow.
Oh, okay.
I'm not quite playing something.
Hold on.
Okay.
What the heck is she doing?
That was funny.
Sorry, I'm locked in.
Good.
Stop with the stupid circles.
I'm tired of this grandpa.
I was out of the way.
That doesn't make any sense.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Christ, not the stupid circles.
I don't know, I didn't want to walk on hands.
Stop!
I don't even know where she is.
I'm stuck.
The neighbor's dog is barking.
You're so close to death.
Just die.
I suppose I did because I got too freaking greedy.
I was kind of over.
I didn't like that run anyways, to be honest.
Hypness must be on price.
Oh, Jesus is there.
Hey, Dad.
Oh, would you hide that I exist?
It's funny because Nix is like Haiti's mom.
It's all mythology.
And it's like he thought that his grandma was his mom.
What was that?
That run-of-the-mill, like, surprise noise.
You tell him, Nix.
One of the best designs in the game as well, aside from chaos.
Oh!
Why did you do that?
You made step-mommy upset.
I can't believe you've done this.
I don't have enough for that.
Meg is employee of the month again, probably because she killed me.
Wait, no!
Dusa, Dusa, Dusa, Dusa, Dusa, my beloved.
Dusa, Dusa.
No!
Oh, there she is.
Dusa, Dusa, Dusa.
Hi.
Oh, my God.
Are you blushing?
You know what I'd like to use your head for, Dusa?
You know what I'd like to use your head for.
Kissing, because you're so cute.
I don't have enough cathodicase.
It's cool that I can, like, reset everything and just...
I could put it all in death defiance.
Oh.
Yo.
Yeah, let's do that.
Mira, is the Mira going to start talking to me?
Why do you keep wanting to talk to me about stuff I already know?
Smack guys against the wall.
Smack, my bitch.
Oh, hi, Boomi.
Hi, handsome.
What's going on?
Oh, you look a mighty E.P.
How are you up to?
What are you doing, E.P. boy things?
Why don't you lay in the bed?
I have it right here.
Boomi, you can't lay on...
Where are you going?
Boomi.
Oh, Boomi boy.
You gotta go over here.
Thank you.
Lay down, big man.
Oh.
Boomi pets.
Where are you going?
Just lay in the bed.
Why are you trying to leave?
Is this bed not up to your standards?
Is it because it's usually Raina's bed and I put it up on the desk and you prefer the other beds?
Where are you going?
He's just walking around my desk and standing in the way of everything.
I can't see my screen.
He under says his pouch is in danger.
Whoa, attack the pouch.
Squeak, squeak, squeak, squeak, squeak.
He doesn't even care.
Live pouch squeaking.
Do you just want pets?
I can give you pets.
How about that?
I'll give you some pets because it seems like you just want pets.
Hi.
Oh, the head rubs.
Oh, yes.
Pet, pet, pet.
Uh-oh, Boomi Slayer is about to be on the case.
Oh, Boomi.
Are you purring?
No, you're not purring, sadly.
You're giving me all this love, but you won't even dane a purr.
How dare.
Oh, you're scratching your chin.
You're scratching your chin.
Oh, I get a little rumble.
Okay.
Yeah, Boomi doesn't purr that often either.
Hi.
Oh, hello.
Oh, you're being so sweet today.
Are you trying to clear your name?
He has full purrs.
Yeah, I haven't got like a full on purr from him since he was a little kitten.
He's just a very reserved young man.
Too good for me, his mother.
He's in his teenage years being a year old.
Oh, he's your boy.
Boomi, you can't stand there though.
Are you going to, do you want to hug?
Is that what you want?
Are you asking for a hug?
You're looking at me like you want to hug.
Oh.
Then you moved in microphone.
Do you want to hug?
Boomi, come here.
Come on.
You're thinking about it.
Sometimes he'll reach up and ask to climb onto my shoulder for a little hug.
Oh, why are you being so sweet right now?
Why don't you just want some love?
I'll give you some love.
He's so clingy, but he's not.
All right, where are you going, boy?
Where are you going?
Are you?
Are you stepping on my lap?
He's rubbing against the microphone.
Are you giving me headbutts and putting your paws on my lap like you're going to come snug?
Are you going to...
Oh my God.
Oh, Boomi hug.
Oh, thank you.
What a good boy.
Such a good boy.
He just climbed onto my shoulder.
This makes me so happy.
He doesn't do this too often.
Hello.
You just want to hug?
He's really having a moment.
Let me have this, okay?
This is rare.
Oh, hi.
Hello.
He's embracing the cuddles.
Can you please get your butt out of my face though?
Okay, he climbed off my shoulder.
He's like, that's enough.
Where will you go, sir?
Will you go where the winds take you?
He literally just snuggled me and left.
He's actually really cute.
He never steals.
What do you mean?
He's always stealing Fiya's food when I'm preparing it for her.
For her syringe.
And I have to like, I whisk it into a mousse before I put in the syringe.
He'll always try to come and take the bowl away from me.
Slander.
It's not slander if it's fact.
Bumi has his moments, but he will always steal from his sister.
Which is the way of things.
Thank you for your snuggles, my people.
Literally though.
Oh, that was really sweet.
Oh, hello.
He has such voluptuous hair.
Ooh.
I can't even see past these freaking things.
My neighbor's dog is barking so much and it's really annoying.
Oh, no.
That was stupid.
Oh, my.
Okay, I already got a palm.
Drunken Dash.
Drunken Fist.
Oh.
Does the hangover...
Oh, wow.
Is that like, sundown momentarily?
I don't even know what, like, the effects of names this one would be due.
I like how they all get so surprised.
The power of the gods.
Juicy.
Oh, please.
This is, ugh.
Lately, I feel like in my later runs, I am just not getting boons.
I'm literally just getting, like, random, like, the status upgrades or, like, whatever, great status.
What are they called?
Oh.
Like the...
You pay for it?
Oh, my God, what am I doing?
Like, those are great, but you guys know what I'm trying to say.
But I just, I really need, I need, I don't care about coins.
Hangovers, basically, poison.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
You get poisoned.
Poison's dead.
Get poisoned, get poisoned, get poisoned.
Well, I feel so slow after dashing around for five minutes.
Get poisoned.
That was actually helpful.
Alright, please.
Aphrodite, thank you.
Aphrodite, my queen.
Aphrodite.
My reaches.
Very insane indeed.
Okay, that was very easy.
Aphrodite, you should.
Oh.
Do you?
Do you want some of this?
Actually, no, I don't want to piss off Aries.
It's very veeler.
I saw, there's like a VTuber group called V-Kiss.
I know Kozichi was in it, which I think is super cute.
And I just thought of V-Kiss, V-Sucky.
I will do the heartbreak flourish again.
Oh, Poseidon, Poseidon, Poseidon, please.
Poseidon, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Poseidon, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Ah!
I might die, actually.
I don't have a kind of a watch.
Ah!
Now, my nose is itchy.
Maybe I should have done a heartbreak.
Please, where'd you dead yet?
There's like a stomachache.
Jesus.
Poseidon!
Xobot, my VTuber face is ending.
Here's money, goodbye.
What?
What do you mean?
Where are you going?
You can never leave.
I will not let you.
I will take my nails and dig them into your skin and you will never leave me.
VTuber face never ends.
You'll be back.
Bye for now.
Thank you for the Supa Exo, though.
I hope you are okay.
He broke the cycle.
Be safe.
I hope you will return.
And I hope in your absence you do what makes you happy.
But I would prefer to you to stay.
And that goes for everyone, don't leave me.
Or I will cry.
What?
Oh, Boomi, you're back.
Come on.
Aram is forever.
Yeah, you guys better not go nowhere.
Boomi will be very upset.
I'll stick Boomi on you.
Boomi, are you gonna keep sitting in front of my screen?
Alright.
I can't really...
He's sitting in front of my other one, so that's fine.
I thought there was a way down.
I'm like, oh, what's this?
I will enter when Boomi leaves the premises.
I did pat the cat.
I patted his head instead of petting it and he looked so goofy.
Don't me and IC's cats look so much alike?
Isn't that crazy?
Boomi looks so much like Lahage.
Or Bakaraj?
I can't remember his name.
They look so much alike except Boomi's lighter.
They literally look identical.
Boomi is laying on my computer keyboard.
Uh...
Thank you for getting off Boomi.
Do you want me to...
I just feel like you don't like this bed.
I'll just get it out of the way for you then.
Here, would you prefer this bed instead?
Or are you just gonna lay on the table?
Where are you going, sweet boy?
Madam, are you sweating?
Oh, I am.
Boomi was sitting on my...
my toggles.
I also just saved a screenshot when I was fixing that.
Here.
Here, do you want a bed?
There's a cozy bed for you.
I know you like this one more.
I will wait for you to get comfy before I start, Boomi.
He's like insisting on not stepping into the bed.
Okay, big man, where are you off to?
Pouch, pouch, pouch, pouch, pouch, pouch.
Are you gonna hop down?
Let me move out of the way.
No, no, he spotted my headphones.
Crap.
Ugh, you're getting heavy.
Boomi doesn't mind being held though.
He's like being picked up.
Cause he's up on my boy.
Where are you going?
Boomi, you can't just stand in front of my screen.
I think he hears a dog and he's like,
what's going on here?
What's this dog doing?
Why are you so mad?
He's flicking his tail.
Do you hear the dog and it's bothering you?
What's up?
Okay, you can hang out right there, I suppose.
It's heavy, that's why he's mad.
I didn't say he was fat, I said he was heavy.
He's a very muscular, large cat.
He is, I've never had a boy cat
and I didn't realize how big they are.
My mom's never let me have a boy cat
because she said he would just be a cat.
But he doesn't even do, he doesn't walk or anything.
Oh no, Boomi, I can't see.
I can't see, I can't, I can't see.
Boomi's not the time to play with my boards.
I desperately need to get out of here.
Do you need help?
What the heck?
How did I dash all the way over there?
Health?
Great.
Seven health and a dream.
Boomi, where are you going?
Okay, thank you.
Are you getting in that bed?
I have like five, I just bought Boomi a new cat bed too.
I bought a cat bed and a toy just for Boomi
and he doesn't even play with the toy.
I got him one of those like scratching boards
that's also like, has a little ball aside
so you can like, the cat can like sit on the scratch board
and like bat the ball in a circle, it's like one of those.
And then, but he loves the new bed.
Excuse me.
Mama puts a no male collapse cat suit.
Have a good night.
Thanks for stopping by.
Boomi's expensive.
I like, I like, like if you come into my house
it'll be like, wow cats definitely live here
because I love spoiling my cats
and getting them lots of nice things.
A fountain chamber.
I would love to see what it's trying to tell me
if I could walk over there.
A place of calm and respite
whilst perhaps unimaginable in the underworld
occasionally is to be found, in fact.
And not a moment too soon.
Yeah, I was freaking dying, bro.
Can I get like more?
I like how there's just like little ghosts
just chilling in it, like yeah.
I might go to Charon
just because I know I can buy another boon off of him.
Sounds like Charon's breathing up ahead.
Charon, sorry.
Um...
I can still...
Can get that.
And then I will buy something from Aries.
Oh.
Rick.
What?
Oh, I thought it said...
I totally read that wrong.
I'm so pissed.
I thought it said that I would get...
It would cost a 20.
But it said it'd restore 20 health.
I feel really dumb.
Ugh.
I am very mad at myself, but what can you do?
What can you do?
Because I'm like, oh, okay, I have enough for both.
I didn't.
I should have done that first.
I wish I had the chain.
The chain would be really good right now.
Get poisoned.
Ow.
Sometimes I feel like things should do way more damage
than they should.
Get poisoned, get poisoned, get poisoned, get poisoned.
Where's the...
Where's the stupid little...
There's not even like the little pile of skulls.
Why are they spawning so much?
Holy crap.
Damn.
Yeah, I was thinking that.
That's hard.
Because these are all actually super helpful.
I'm debating whether or not...
Because I've only seen a...
There hasn't been too many armored people.
I'll do...
Yeah, armor is annoying.
Let's do that.
I'll do...
Don't get it.
Yeah, let's first.
I didn't think you'd be able to reach me.
Get poisoned, get poisoned, get poisoned, get poisoned, get poisoned.
Oh, why are there so many of you?
Okay, the poison helps a lot, actually.
Nice.
Let's go see Sharon again,
because now I have more.
Hi.
Ooh.
Cool.
What is this?
My question?
Random boom.
Boom.
Oh, deal more damage,
but that's like 10%, but that's like 15%.
I don't really have anything on my...
Yeah, I'm gonna do the cast,
because I don't have anything on my cast.
Which one should I improve with the Hall of Power?
Yeah, I was thinking that,
because I use my special a lot.
Yeah, okay.
I'll pay for that.
That's pretty cool of you, Sharon.
I guess money does help sometimes.
Okay.
Maybe I could just spam dash on her.
You can't stop thinking about me.
Ooh.
You think of me in pain?
Oh my God, she's literally me for real.
Oh, nope.
I'm not gonna press start,
because Reyna's thinking of jumping on my desk right now.
Hi, Reyna.
What's up?
I'm gonna need you to skedaddle, sweetie.
Reyna.
Okay, come say hi.
Come on.
Hi.
Hi, Reyna.
Oh, you wanna hug too?
Okay.
Hug time.
Is that too loud, by the way?
It's not too loud.
Okay, you can hear me fine, though.
Okay, cool.
Reyna is burning in my arms.
And as usual, pulling my headphones out of my way.
Sorry, I'm just chilling in the petting cat.
Reyna.
I'll be more and be more specific.
I'm really sorry.
I'm just like disassociating while I'm petting Reyna.
Oh, I'm trying to put her on down,
and she's like holding onto my shoulder.
How are you guys doing?
I'm doing okay.
I'm thinking about what I'm gonna make for dinner.
I'm just chilling, yeah.
Rushing Reyna.
Me holding you, you purring in my arms.
What are choices for dinner?
I made myself for lunch salmon and rice,
and I don't know what I'm gonna make for dinner
because I don't want salmon and rice again.
Yeah, I definitely should go grocery shopping again.
This is salmon out for 24 hours?
No, it wasn't.
Wait, my cheek is the wrong color.
Why is that?
Got soup?
Do I have soup?
No, I don't have any soup.
I finished the stew.
I'm just thinking she has only one wing.
How does she fly?
The soup is salmon running away in water,
that's what I'll say.
Water and flour.
For dinner?
Girl.
I don't know how to make it.
I didn't know that.
I can make it.
For dinner?
Girl dinner indeed some eggs. I don't like I don't like eating eggs
Like I'll eat eggs, but they're not my first choice or anything. I
Don't know why I
Was thinking about them the other day
I don't know why I just don't like eggs anymore like I'll still eat anything with eggs in it, but
Imagine you're out of a crusticles. Yes, I've been out of a crusticles. It is a tragedy. I
Could be waste of a PBJ
I should make shrimp gumbo
Do I have frozen shrimp, I don't think I do I think I only have frozen salmon
Actually, I could make spaghetti because I have pasta. I have pasta sauce. I have meatballs
I also have sausages, but I would have to defrost those
Oatmeal is pretty good. I
Can make condiment soup. That's a guy guys. I have gone grocery shopping
Lake in the last few weeks like it's not like I have not gone grocery
I
Think some of you have been here for a bit. We're like she still hasn't gone grocery shopping
Hasn't she she only has caught like half food. I'm just thinking of what to make
Oh God grocery shopping my mom took me because I was too sick
And then hindsight I shouldn't have gone because I discovered I have a head COVID
And I didn't know because I only had motion sickness no other symptoms
Let's take why don't you guys make me dinner?
Give us a I'm not give you a list. I don't know I
Bought a lot of groceries. I bought two hundred and fifty dollars in groceries
And I got three things with that money
You'll share some share some lasagna. Yeah, mail it to me and hope that it doesn't go bad
I do have I have one apple juice in my fridge. Actually, no, it's a lie because I have I have apple juice
from simply natural and then I have honest
kids fruit pouches for apple juice because I am a child and
in in Minecraft not really
And I have I like actually I
Have I I have no I actually finished the pop tarts for breakfast. I had blueberry pop tarts for breakfast
Hundred on a cross the bulls with you an apple juice under the cat's truth
Yeah, I spent two hundred dollars on the cats the other day
So I could get them their food litter some toys some treats for them a
Bed for boomy because via took his bed. Well, she didn't take his bed. I gave
I
Feel doesn't even like that bad that much, but it's just cozy for her to be in because it keeps them warm
So I got on the same bed in a different color. He was very pleased
Yeah, I know got me the toy cat wait to use that in the house of blue
The house of Brooklyn
Okay, I think I'm ready to roll. I think I will make spaghetti after this
Oh
What the hell get poison get poison get poison get poison. Oh, I'm dead
Get poison get poison get poison get poison poison
Now why are you doing I'm I'm not focused. I'm worried. I
Think I rely on that
Get poisoned get poison get poison get poison. Oh, I didn't even know that I died
I
Need a 25k 25k what okay, she got me subscribers money
Where the heck did you just come from you must be pretty used to dying you or something else aren't you?
Hey
Can someone please help me break into my father's bed chambers anyone anyone
Dash dash get poison good boys and good boys
Right here and all did you and mother how to put this any brothers and sisters? That's a weird ask
Damn
Oh my god, I have weak blood in a bad temperament
Well, who do I get her from my dad?
Did you have an accident baby
Jesus that makes me feel so bad since when is my dad such a dick
I
Why do you keep leaving me not as comfy as it looks no
Do so I just want to love you
That was rena sneezing are you okay?
Did you stick your face into the water bowl again you look like you did and you seized on the water
Yes, that was her sneezing bless you my child bless you rena. Are you okay?
Oh
Raina comes when she's called cuz she's a good cat
You're circling me like a shark and I can't keep up with or you are
Okay
Do I
No way I have Lily I need one more
Wait
So I can either get two or five seconds, I think that's fine
I
Can't talk to you right now. You're not really helpful. Oh, but I would get a bonus
1% dodge chance that doesn't seem that impressive one more time
No, wait, no death's defiance
Did I actually do that? You're not a fit. No death defiance. I
Didn't notice that of course. It's my Poseidon run. I forget to do death defiance. I
Really like the title dash
Can't see past this thing
Oh
Gemstones
I already have the death defiance off so
You know where you are
Sorry chaos
I'm tempted to do the cast or the attack hi boomie
I
Wait, why are you guys crying?
I'm gonna do the sauce
Chat is stuck in the video what's new
Oh, wow, I'm so so
That's why I another reason why I like this attack
Oh, no
Boomy hi, have you come to visit?
I
Think boomie ever since I let him lay on the my desk I moved my keyboard and everything he just wants to lay there now
He just insists on sitting in front of me
Hi pretty boy, you gotta move
I'm patting you I'm patting you
Are you chewing on my headphones butt pat butt pat butt pat?
No, let my headphones go
Let my headphones go
Please don't chew on them
For me
I'm gonna hold you like a baby. You're gonna go in baby deal
Go over there
No sir, you can't he tries to pick it up with little hands little otter hands
I'm gonna
I don't know what I'm gonna do
Can you move please can you not chew on boomie's trying to take my
Ha
He just freaking
Grab my headphone wire in his mouth and I knew what was coming because that's when I
He has his like posture when he's gonna jump off like he's gonna take something and run off with it
and so he just
Grabbed my headphones and jumped down and ripped my headphones out of my ears
Because he was trying to make off with them. I'm telling you this man is a menace. He's a villain. He just tried to steal from me
He just yoinked my headphones out of my ears because he was trying and he almost unplugged me. Did he unplug them?
No, he didn't but he'll do that with his toy like I'll I'll be playing with him with the toy like a um
Like a like a little like feather wand and then he'll just like grab
The end of the toy yank it out of my hands and run away with it. I'm like, that's not how this is played
He thought they were dangerous
He just wants attention
Oh, yeah, oh, oh no, I'm very close to death. Oh, at least I can just unlock you
I'm so slow
Oh
You can't get me you can't get me
Oh, I'm so slow I live 26
Oh, maybe I can get some health. Let's see
Someone to spend some coin
It's also just a nice reprieve
No, all right
Hey, what's up Sharon? You are a cypher sore eyes. They're cairon. Sorry cairon cairin
Brilliant okay, I have more money
No
Sharon
Yeah, I know I love this game
He appeared thunder he just tried to what do mean justice for boomi. He just tried to steal from me
Now he's sitting on the cat tree like he didn't do anything
Oh, this is great. Wait, did I get the 400 armor? I don't even remember
Oh
Okay, that's fine that was it sucks because I forgot to put on death defiance, but I kind of stopped taking it seriously after that
Damn giant evil crystal
Uh, what do you want? Oh, hi. I'm welcome home again. Go right ahead. What did my dad do?
Joy
Something leaking from the room
You're getting somewhere with that codex lad. I'm pleased to see it
My duties to the house. I'll try to travel for the boat. Sorry. I read fast
Hades themed ASMR. What could I possibly do?
For that
Oh, I just died. Oh, I'm back. Oh, here's my run. Who is that?
Thanatos featured servant of the house. Oh
Have I seen Thanatos?
Beating the listener to death
Role play nix because role play meg. Oh, that's a good point. Oh wait mom
My mother because you raised me
Next do you know anything about a softly spoken gentle being under the guise of chaos?
They approached me recently and offered me a boon of sorts
Primordial chaos
Indeed, I know them well
They must have taken interest in your quest
I understand. What is this freaking ghost cheesing next to me about? Did you see he's just like
It ran off. What is funny ms. Dusa did I?
I don't have any nectars. I give her one. Do I have can I like exchange something?
Five for a nectar
I would have given her one, but no do so where'd you go?
My blind were do so go. Usually she's so so so around. Oh, there she is
Oh, she didn't run away that time
Nix's offspring of chaos
Hey
I need to neck to her. I didn't get any shadow stuff
So I'm not even gonna bother with that
Wait, no, I do need to bother with that
Just need to fix that
You
Cut nectar cut nectar
Um
Plop plop plop get nectar get nectar. They don't even pay me to do it. I'm gonna start calling it nectar
Okay
You ready
Time you learn the bearing of the gods and to assert yourself
For this I have employed what does this mean? What does bearing mean or what became of him? What?
What
This one's for you Achilles
Oh, what
Is this supposed to be a nod to asbestos
Bearing as a word he used in his sentence wow
That's it
What I can go to chaos off the rip. Yeah
Fucking I will
Oh Daedalus is hammer. I'm so dumb. Listen. I'm tired. I just hit me
That makes sense because nix has the same skulls on her body
Thank you
Oh
Thank you, I just won't cast
I probably should have looked at the little thingy
Okay
All right, I'll talk to Artemis
Pog
Oh
What oh, no, I didn't mean to press that
That was so weird. It just didn't do anything. It didn't do the attack
I was pressing square like what the frick. I'm so thrown off now
That was so weird. Is this the run? I don't know
I
Can literally just boost the crap out of my special
Oh
A curse of chaos has been lifted
Worth it
Can I please get like boons for health
The special is crazy on this run
Let's check it
Whoa
Oh my god
It took a while. All right, let's just
That was not as effective as I thought it would be
However that this would be good for the armor thing
Another key
Hmm
I kind of want to be able to inflict hangover for the quick dash. I prefer it rather than
Whatever his thing is to be honest with you. So I might go with him
Yeah, they're both boss chambers so no matter which one I do I'll probably face the jewels again
You think Aries dash is better
That's true. Okay, I'll do areas
Oh, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
Oh
I'm fucking this up. I'm I'm fucking it up. Oh, oh my god. Oh my why am I stuck here?
Ah
Why do I feel like my special is not doing as much to okay, there we go
I'm like, what's happening here?
Yeah, I'm a death dealer Harry Potter
And it doesn't even have the dash there's not even the dash here
Because they already used death defying so am I gonna get more bonus damage?
You say one, all right, let's do one
The will to fight
Oh three only works for the room you're in that makes sense
What does the doom effect do
Let's go see Sisyphus
Okay, interesting. Hi. She has been giving me a time. I wish she would let me pass
She is made the cover. Oh sweet. I can finally get a nectar. I'm surprised I hadn't been getting any nectar drops
I
Guys are so spread out. I can't do my chain attack
There you go
But I'm pointing this way
Oh, this is like nasty. This is one shot. What why are they still coming?
Okay, that was just like wacky
Oh, you're giving me a palm. Okay. What we got here
That time to be a little short of coin
Hmm, I could do that I'm gonna save my money
Oh my god, my special is insane now my special I can even talk
Hmm
Oh my god, my special is off the chisane. What the
I'm like, I see him coming for me. What's happening here?
Oh my god
No, I'm uh
More power
Um, let's get more of this
Oh
Oh chaos hi
That's nasty chaos, what's up? Oh, I can give you a gift. You know, I'm gonna give chaos a gift
Because I bet they have a crazy thing
Because you've been a real one
It tends to tend to be the interior
Oh, okay. I'm sorry. You're too cool for that
That is chaotic. They're like, this is stupid here. I'll give you something in return
Cosmic egg
Fascinating
In the name of Hades
Oh my god
If I just don't use my attack, oh, that's my cat's food going off
Oh
I'm gonna
I'm gonna see if I can buy some help I'm a health
What
Why is it 125?
Are you serious bro, whatever I'll frickin take this while I'm here
Well, I can't even use the thing because I didn't have any other places to go
Should have gone to the palm. You're right
I
Can't use my attack
Ow
Stop chasing me
Oh
Oh, no
I don't know about this one bros
Did I just step on the freaking thing
No
I blew it I blew it
Oh
Sad
Don't laugh at me
Rude
Oh
Court music
Well, he's been very helpful
So
They wish to help you for my dad's a dick. I'm pleased to hear you say
Oh, hello mother hold on. What's the latest?
Can you tell me something more of chaos next my place is not to speak too openly of chaos child
It is their own prerogative sick never mind
Dusa frick I didn't use the nectar on you
I'm so sorry Dusa. I used it on chaos because they were there. I'm such a terrible person
Got stepped on by Artemis. Uh, I have 119
Oh
Power
Yeah, I want to see what what did chaos give me he gave me an egg
No, I didn't mean to
Give me varotha back
Oh
Give me that
Oh my god chaos you're about to be my best friend
Chaos is about to be my best friend egg. Hold on. I'm gonna go make some ramen
That'll be quick and easy to do
And I'll keep chatting with you guys while I do it
I hit up the stretch
I have some bold after all men
Oh movie. What are you doing? You're trying to seduce Reina. She's not interested
Stop trying to seduce this old woman. Don't sniff her butt, but she's trying to eat weirdo
Hi Reina
Yeah, how are you doing girl?
You're so hilarious
You
I
Sorry to play with fear for a second. Okay, I'm gonna heat up some wawa
That's crazy
I want my spear. I won't get to the other weapons later
I
Just want to be have my spear all the time and the staff people with my fork
I put a little bit of the spicy sauce in the ramen
I
Boil some wawa in a pot
Wait, what do you mean? I can upgrade the spear
Explain yourselves, how do I upgrade the spear with Titan foot?
I'm having the pink package bull duck ramen. It's like the carbonara
Um while I'm waiting for my stuff to boil. I'm going to try to be
Um
I
I little girl
Hi, it's your chatty you want some
It's for you
What why are you?
She's like I don't want to be hold like a baby and fed like a baby
If you guys can see it right now you'd be like, oh my god. She's a baby
Here you go
What you
Come on
I did feed her a little bit later this morning. Um well this afternoon
So I'm wondering if she's like full and she's like, hey, I'm not ready yet ma'am
Would you like some
Come on. I know you want some of you
She's a fussy baby
I'm just thinking this is um her meow. This is her that's her irritated meow like
More of the time she's like meow. She's her meow is usually more higher pitched
This is that's her uh
Why have you done this to me mother meow?
All right, you want some of this? Oh, yeah
Some cat feeding ASMR
I
Know
She's just a little baby
Girl you're going too fast I can't keep up
She's still not on solid solid food yet, so I puree everything for her
Um, but sometimes she'll have the strength to like chew on some kibble, which is a very good sign
Can you guys hear going the life bad companion?
Boomi go away. He's trying to steal her food
That's enough boomi
I
Good girl fia. Ah, you just flicked food at my face. Thank you
Do you two really like anything bunny? Yeah, that's a good one
Fia stop moving your head
Boomi boomi back up boomi you need to stop you literally just ate I watched you eat with reina
Boomi haven't you stolen enough you stolen everybody's hearts
Can you hear going that's her sucking on the syringe
She's like a little baby
Good girl
I'll give you some treats afterwards too
Boomi's just making sure she's okay if you could see him he's desperately trying to get to the syringe so he can drink from it
Yeah defend that boomi's lawyer defend that
You know I gotta let you breathe a moment lady breathe
Boomi boomi
Yeah, that's what I thought
Making sure it's not poisoned
No video evidence
I
Move the mic down so you guys can hear her she just heard you know, you know, baby
Sometimes the food gets stuck in the syringe and it actually like shoots out
I have to be careful not to like make it explode all over the place
There you go
I think my water finally finished boiling in the pot
But I've only fed Fia half the syringe so I'm gonna try to feed her the rest before I
I always eat feed her before I feed myself
Can you get your little baby?
And boomi's just sitting in front of my screen nothing there
This is a cat being fed by a syringe youtube nothing bad
And boomi's is watching
It's very disappointedly that he's not being fed like this
I have to feed my babies before I can continue stream Fia you got some in your nose
Good girl
Yes, I did name boomi after boomi king of umashu because he was such a crazy kitten
Are you surprised? I don't know. I just
Some people would give up on her
And I just can't do that. I'm gonna
Work hard for my little girl
She's just such a sweet soul
How could I not oh this piece does not want to come out
Here
Is there a piece that's stuck again
I don't want this just to explode boomi you can't have this
Eagle
Fia I'm sorry. There's like a piece stuck in the syringe. I have to get it out. There you go. Are you done?
No, okay
Your sister's he is staring so intensely. Hi boomi at the
The the thing at the syringe because he wants them so bad
I mean, I'm preparing the food boomi will steal from it. He's licked half the bowl clean when I walked away before
And I was like no that was for your sister
Oh my god, this won't come out
I don't want to have to use my mouth on it because this is like duck
I can't get it out
Gross
Trying to suck it out and I can't
Boomi does want the fancy food
Fia, I'm sorry baby girl
It's like a giant piece of food stuck in the syringe and I don't want to explode everywhere and I'm trying to squeeze it out
But it's not working
She's like waiting patiently like mother where's the rest
You
And it's funny because I always give boomi a little bit when I'm preparing her food, but then he just wants to take it all
There's no
If they do fine, it's not like they're taking a lot from me anyways. Oh
Did I just score it out? I just don't want to shoot at my computer
There you go
Yeah, it's back to normal. Nope. Sorry just bonked you on the nose
Uh actually, nope, it's not back to normal
Oh
It just squirted everywhere no fia I got it on your face and I got it over my arm
I have to wipe your face after this you're no messy baby
I
Hear boomi you want some of that?
Boomi's licking my hands. Thank you actually
Cat eating food ASMR
I
That's the first like a dictator
Sorry for you. Let me wipe your face because you got some of the food on your face, you little girl.
You're so good. Even when Boomi's trying to steal everything. Here, you can have the last of it.
Good girl. Good girl.
Boomi just tripped on my desk and it was funny.
Okay.
Fia, you ate that pretty fast.
Why are you growling?
Just wiping your face.
Is it because Boomi's taking your food?
She's like not happy.
Yeah, I know. I need to burp you.
Yeah, that's Fia.
I have to co-podge you. Co-podge.
You don't want to, when you syringe feed any sort of animal, you want to even kind of make sure that it's a little bit thicker so their body differentiates so they don't asphyxiate on it.
So I usually will burp her afterwards.
No, it's in a teak kettle. I just boiled it in a teak kettle. It's fine.
It's also probably just uncomfortable to be held like a baby and then fed.
And it's hard for her to understand what's going on because I'm moving her around a lot.
She mostly will meow out of frustration because she can't move. She's like, eh, come on.
Good girl. Oh, you're so good.
How you burp a cat like a baby? Exactly.
I'm a hard-working mother.
Okay, yeah, you want to say bye to them?
Yeah.
There you go.
Good girl. Let me get you a wipe so I can wipe your face.
Why are you looking at me like that, Bowie?
I gave her a bath the other day and she looks so goofy.
She looks like you so so.
She looks like one of those cats in those commercials.
Like in the arms of an angel.
And I'm like, girl, why are you trying to look so pathetic?
You're just in a sink being cleaned.
Yes, I was burping feet over my shoulder. That's why you hear those patting noises.
Alright, she's laying in the bed now on my desk and she looks already super tired.
So now I'm going to go make my ramen. Excuse me, cats.
There's 50 of you, just two, but, you know, 50.
Raina, can you say please? Raina.
Can you say please? That's it.
Good girl.
Bowie, you could wear a thing or two from your elders.
Raina, speak.
Raina, that was too quiet. Raina, speak.
Raina.
Raina, what's going on?
Speak.
Okay, you're just silent, Bowie. It's fine.
Hey, Bill, you there?
She doesn't need to give you just.
I mean, Raina, you speak. She went...
Hi.
I wonder how the cats don't hate water.
tub um so I feel so I cling to you in the sink and um you always want to put a towel down just so
that they because they they don't have traction in a tub um or in a sink so you so the one that's
once they can grip on to something on in the water then they're fine um it also is hard for them
it's kind of frightening because of how their coats work they get really weighed down so that's
why it's something to the sense of panic um I believe you're coming to check on for you
making sure you can't pass my hand girl get down dude if you have some space
here you can call my chair because you get
don't honk at me
you got the zoos
boy we got the zoos
so I don't like a lot of water in my roman to be honest with you
I don't like a lot of broth unless it's like traditional roman but if it's like um
it's like package roman
then I'm like
all right
a little bit less
and I only put a little bit of the old up spicy uh
spicy stuff in mine because I don't handle spice that well
my four bears are very disappointed I'm sure
and then I'll put
some meat in it if I have any but I would have advice the sausage was defrosted I would
sausage is indeed frozen I should probably put that out
hello
our ramen is in the boiling water it'll take like three minutes
we can check
what are you looking at me like that for
for you
macaroni
with the chicken strips
this is now a cooking channel
madam take care of you while you're sick how funny that's actually the asmr that's um
going to happen next week
hope you made enough for boomi too boomi gets his food from the food dispenser
he gets his food and he sits and he eats but then he wants to
take fee of special food that I make for her because she can't chew
no it's not the next patreon it's the next asmr as in um what's it called uh dislike youtube
sorry sorry if you thought it was patreon
how did I get here I don't know hello you must have traveled far and wide aka
you were passed around from uh stream to stream as someone rated into the other
oh
packs the cup oh my gosh my lord
that's that's a little bit intense now
but hi if you're new here and you've just woken up from being stream rated across the lands
my name is sheebie cotton bum and I'm your favorite girl failure dom
of uh gen one vealer indulge and I am a goofy girl I guess I'm here to stay
yeah we got another one boys we got another one um let me make myself a little smaller
for boomi thank you what is he gonna do with that why do you pay him for his crimes
thank you for the soup oh my god
I'm telling you I'm gonna have to do like some sort of court roleplay thing
boomi versus the people boomi's pay his lawyer boomi he knows boomi is fine no he knows boomi
needs to pay his fines and he's bailing him out
oh
she be just twitter have his own boom twitter tags um I was actually for fee
thank you so much oh for fia yeah fia justice for fia thank you stash power that's so kind of you
um oh that's very she's like grooming herself right now she looks really funny while she does it
um since she can only really move her head she's like looking at her shoulders she looks funny
but she says thank you ready oh she's licking my hand as a thank you she says thanks
um I want to do like make an account for boomi I just have to just like how shondo does for her cat
a health care for fia justice for boomi correct love for fia yeah she's been doing she's been um
improving which makes me happy hi you know what you mean
do I have to close your eyes for you the thing is like the paralysis will reach her face
and then she can't like blink properly it looks creepy because she is like cats have an inner
a secondary eyelid or a third eyelid rather just like um like reptiles so like she'll fall asleep
technically with her eyes open and I'll have to like close your eyes to be like you're good
yeah rena rena stands above all oh no it's a it's a donation war between fia boomi
hashtag rape boomi rena on the quee shit
yeah cats have a third eyelid so like um so a way that they test cats reflexes for their their
face for their nerves in their faces they tap um the inside uh inner corner of their eye
and you'll tell if the cats faces um paralyzed if like the second eyelid comes up or um if they
just don't react at all and so like sometimes to test her I'll just like tap the area and
she's just like reptilian and I'm like ah um justice for foomi
who's foomi thank you a day to war here for the soup um I'll explain if you're new um boomi is one
of my cats B U M I boomi king of umashu and he is kind of a silly cat and then I have fia who is my
she's my special needs cat and she's a very good girl and then there's oh no what about justice
for feet you guys are terrible I think you're average amphibian and all this justice for boomi
um and then there's rena who is just a 14 year old old woman who's just like these kids
are driving me insane there's a needy son even jp for you to forgive foomi afox that's so funny
I don't watch uh a lot of jp talents um but boomi so
did you hear that growling did you hear that that was boomi chasing reina and reina was growling
at him thank you josh foomi supremacy he's harassing older ones why do you protect him
did you hear did you hear him go oh because he literally attacked reina we didn't attack her
he leapt at reina reina turned around and said leave me alone and growled and then he ran off
going oh boomi is my spirit animal your spirit animal harasses the special needs and and old women
oh sleepy girl you mad at me no okay just to check if she's mad I'll be like are you mad
and she'll just lick my hand I'm like thank you those are allegations this is the cat y'all
and exactly exactly why are you defending this cat should be defending my little girl
boomi's just the harem why are you licking my hand so much are you gonna eat me
maybe I'll see if I can feed you more after I don't want to over feed you
you still got a poop girl poop poop poop poop
as you know that you can squeak you can uh express a cat splatter there is a way that you can um
press on the inside of uh outside obviously in the leg near the leg like the back legs
and you can press and you it shoots out like a little squirt gun
when I went to the vet they were like oh do you know how to express her bladder and I'm like no
and in my head I'm like why the hell would I know that why would I how why would I know how to make
force a cat to pee no and so she showed me and she's like okay so hold her for a second and so
I'm holding her and she like gets that little pee pad and then uh she's like okay so if like
fee has trouble peeing you just do this to her you take your hand like this and then you like
push push it here and then it'll be like then all of a sudden it was like and I'm like holy crap
I'm like holy crap what the heck fia fia you turned into a super soaker for pee
I didn't want to know that well now you do you never know when it can save a cat's life
um so so I don't thankfully I don't have to do that like it was uh I did the other day but
now she can go by herself um but like she hadn't peed in like a couple days and I'm like girl you
gotta go and so I did it and I was like oh my god there's so much
so this is an educational stream you can't you can't demonetize me this is educational
how does fia feel she's quite frustrated actually that growl you hear that again boomers
to the believers in chat we order a case against shibi cotton bomb has to take justice for booby
what case against shibi cotton bomb hash justice for booby and hash health care for fia
yeah accomplices to his crimes that's what they are accomplices to his crimes
they you all should be arraigned and brought to court your honor I have hired multiple private
investigators and have found that not only is booby guilty of all of his crimes but he also has
multiple accomplices in this very courtroom demanding his freedom wait was that a double
oh I read it twice sorry booby's lawyer to all the believers in chat we will
win our case against shibi cotton bomb hashtag justice for booby and health care for fia also
what tag for fan cams for kitties oh fan cams for the cams um I don't know you guys can come up with
that oh my god would it be hashtag justice for booby would be the tag for the cat fan cams
booby fia the king of rain no no booby the deathbed companion of rain no that sounds terrible
uh justice for booboo I don't know cat says we all contended meows the name I don't know I'm
trying to think of a punny punny thing
uh
This is a small bowl, I decided to mix this in, so it's kind of a bad idea.
What are you doing?
Boomi, did you find your toy?
He's walking around with a spray in his mouth.
What are you doing?
Oh yeah, I also got them a clay tunnel.
And Boomi and Prada love the clay tunnel, and I know Fia will once she gets back on her feet.
Mixing, mixing, mixing, we are mixing.
This flavor is so good.
The carbonara one, I didn't realize it's even like a little cheesy, which is I think carbonara has the cheesiness that I'm just done.
You should sell with paper towels for what's called messes with Boomi names.
Hi, mister.
What are you doing?
Yeah.
Oh, thank you for the headbutt.
The trouble me hours.
The cat and bums?
Oh, actually a hashtag cat and bum.
That'd be funny.
Cat and bum.
Fia's looking at me like you're going to share some of that, and I'm like, no.
You have the disposition of a sickly Victorian child right now, Fia.
You cannot have this.
It is spicy.
Thank you guys for all the soupas.
You guys are absolutely insane.
Ridiculous, even.
How dare you?
How dare you support Boomi?
Out of everybody here.
What?
What did you do?
What are you doing?
Can you guess who that was?
That was Boomi yelling.
Yeah, you thought it was Raina.
It was not.
Boomi, did you?
No, he makes that meow when he loses something and he wants my help.
He knocked his toy under the fridge, so I'm going to go get it for him.
The noodles are spicy.
Yeah, he does get...
I was really spending time with him earlier, so I don't know.
He just wants to hang out.
Hi.
Hi, handsome.
What did you do with it?
Where'd you go?
You knocked it?
It's okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm going to get it for you.
You have to step out of the way so I can get it.
Yes, you're very sweet.
Hey, Boomi.
Something's still in the water.
Oh, are you?
Get it.
I got it.
Yeah.
Here you go.
I don't know how I'm supposed to do this.
All right.
Sorry.
My son lost his toy.
Good night.
Have a good one.
I'm Fia head out.
I'm feeling EP.
Feline EP.
I like the puns.
Boomi asking for help after a time when you say...
And then you see...
Yeah, cat and bums.
I like cat and bums.
You see what I have to deal with?
He takes and he takes and he does not give.
Right, Fia?
How are you doing?
You're looking mighty content right now.
Your ear is kind of messed up when I picked it up for you.
There you go.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, why are you so freaking cute, Fia?
He gives us an antagonist for the stream.
That's his purpose to be the antagonist.
He gives pouch.
Are you purring?
I can hear you.
Oh, you little girl.
Are you trying to purr?
My son is coming.
Yeah, when you have like cats, you kind of can pick up what they're trying to say.
Fia, are you purring?
Oh, why are you so cute?
I'm trying to think of what was the difference between picking up Fia and Boomi,
because they're not like actual siblings or month apart.
I rescued them from the same rescue, however,
they're not from the same litter.
Fia's just staring at me and purring, and it's really cute.
Little girl.
Wait, I thought I got donated 200 again, but it was just the thing.
Boomi was super noisy on the ride home.
I had to drove four hours to go get him.
Drove into another state, because they didn't bring pets to my area.
This cat voice isn't even supposed to talk.
And he was a very eepy baby.
Raina hated him off the rip, which is why I got Fia,
because I wanted Boomi to have a friend.
He was very snuggly. He always wanted to curl up on your chest.
He always wanted to play.
He never really meowed. He only recently started meowing.
To convey, is Boomi still freaked out by Zumba? Yes, he is.
I've only ran it that one time, because I wanted to give him a break in between.
My floor hasn't been covered in litter, so it's been fine.
I think I took a picture or video of Boomi and Raina playing with each other,
because of the tunnel, and I almost cried, because it was so precious.
I'm sorry to talk about my cats so much, but they're in my entire life.
Meows are just developed by cats, because they figured out that we are more responsive when they talk to us.
They're Siamese cats. They're all Siamese cats, though.
Siamese cats are very talkative, but Fia doesn't usually meow at all.
She only meows in the state, and when she's playing with a toy.
Raina meows all the time.
Boomi meows when he wants something, or when he's really, really happy to see me.
But most of the time, he does that little brrrr noise.
People complain about cats? No, no, no, guys, guys.
Nobody ever complains about anything.
When I also, I noticed that some people thought that from my tweet about me getting tan skin,
that people were hating on me, nobody was.
I was just saying, hey, if you don't like it, then suck it up.
But that's not me. People aren't actively hating on anything that I do.
So don't worry about me in that sense.
Yeah, Raina will sing. She was singing this morning.
And actually, she was singing right before I started to stream.
Fia has purred herself to sleep, but it's quite precious.
Yeah, I always just get out in front of stuff, 100%.
This ramen isn't that good.
The first time I had this ramen, it was delicious.
And then the last batch I made wasn't good, and then this isn't that good,
and I don't know what I'm doing wrong. What did I do differently?
I wonder if it's just like the batch and not me, because I'm like,
these noodles don't have a weird texture. They're not the same ones as before.
Kiddler.
No, I don't follow a recipe. I just kind of make it just packaged ramen.
Boomi, what are you doing? I heard Boomi sneezing.
Could you be getting sick?
I was just sick, so I hope not.
What are you doing this year?
Ow, what is this stuff on me?
Honey!
Now my mouth is on fire.
I'm on fire!
I want a strawberry milkshake.
Guys, I'm craving a strawberry milkshake.
Okay, I'm shutting off the light for Fiya, so my tracking might be a little bit wonky.
Because I'm going by the light on my computer.
It will kill you, no!
Not if I do like, if I take a lactate, like I never do.
That's true, I have done that before.
It's an extra step, walking to my bathroom, going to the medicine drawer,
pulling out the medicine, putting the medicine in my mouth, swallowing the medicine.
I'm going to the medicine drawer, pulling out the medicine, putting the medicine in my mouth, swallowing the medicine.
If that was a way to go, I'd die from a milkshake.
What flavor milkshake would a Zura make?
If you die, who will take care of their kitties?
Damn it, you got me.
A Zura flavor? Minty?
Oh wait, you're right.
Mint chocolate chip? Ooh, that would be tasty.
I feel like I would be like a strawberry because of the red.
I think emi would be like an orange creamsicle.
I see naturally would be lemon, or lemon blueberry.
And then strawnee could be like a green apple.
Wait, no, I'm thinking of snowcombs now.
Sherbet for emi.
Why sherbet? Why strawnee?
Strawnee would be like strawberry shortcake flavor.
Then that dives into what strawberry shortcake character?
Am I? Sorry.
Ooh, pumpkin. Duh, pumpkin.
Pumpkin? Oh my god, like a spiced pumpkin milkshake.
Oh my god, perfect for fall.
Oh, that sounds delicious. I'm gonna eat milkshake emi.
Great for mercy? Hmm.
I think, does mercy like coffee?
I don't think she does, because I feel like she would have a coffee flavor.
Fall is red. Fall is my favorite season. I love fall so much.
You got renaissance fairs, you got halloween, you got my birthday, you got um,
you got uh, what else do you get? Leaves?
I also just prefer the cold over the hot.
That's why I haven't gone outside so much.
Grape ice cream? I've never heard of grape ice cream.
No, don't. Sorry, I'll stop talking.
I was thinking, because my dad was like, you need to leave your house and go for a walk.
And I'm like, there's a gym in my apartment and I'm like, you know what,
I'm gonna start going for walks again. I need your guys help to motivate me.
I want to like, I'm trying, I need to strengthen my body a little bit.
I've been a little bit too sedentary when I since have become a streamer.
Where at my last job, I was on my feet for eight hours a day, essentially.
Minus, actually yeah.
Because I clocked out for lunch for an hour, because it was a nine hour shift and I have an hour lunch.
Yeah, so about eight hours.
Good food. I know I need to.
I'm telling you, I'm trying to get like, hello fresh or like, factor to like, sponsor me.
Because it was actually, because of the structure of the food,
it was just easier for me, like that type of person I am to make it more walkies.
Yeah, walkies.
Yeah, I need to get stronger. I'm just a frail, sickly child right now.
I feel like, like simple tasks have been hard for me. I don't know if it's my fibro progressing,
but my mom always said, because my mom is fibro too, that like the best thing she ever did was keep moving.
And so I'm like, yeah, maybe I need to do that.
Yeah, I like hello fresh.
I used to I used to eat that a lot.
You take any multiple vitamins? No, I just take my meds.
I used to take a multivitamin. Maybe I should do that again.
I think they I had like the vitamin gummies.
I don't know if they're still good because I have some still.
She be Jim arc.
I want to be able to because I like I can like lift a lot of my legs.
Cystic fibrosis no fibromyalgia.
Moving where what moving to outside and coming back inside.
But yeah, like you guys are keep telling me like you've been going to the gym and I haven't since I love because my job one of the cool benefits of my job was I got like free gym stuff.
So I would go to like the gym and then my apartment just got a gym.
And because it was closed for some time for whatever reason I can't recall.
So I'm like, oh, but I hate like the gym in my apartment. It's kind of dumb.
So I'm like, you know what?
Let me let me I need to try to eat better. I need to lay off the uncrustables.
Um, it's not like it's not like weight related. It's just like, I know like I'm putting like bad food in my body and it's not helping with my pain or anything.
I honestly, what's a weird thing is that so I've been gluten free and dairy free before.
And that was the best I felt.
My mom is gluten free and dairy free for the sake like for some odd reason.
American gluten just like does stuff to you and dairy causes inflammation.
So I think I might start drinking almond milk again and avoiding gluten.
It's just hard to do because there's not a lot of stores near me that sell gluten free items.
But I think there's like a Whole Foods nearby.
Maybe I can go to or like a Trader Joe's.
I know I have to say goodbye to uncrustables though.
Yeah, it's awkward because it's my they're my neighbors and I don't want them to see me.
Your throat just makes like they hard.
I need to like my my legs like surprisingly for having been sitting mostly for the past few months being a VTuber.
I still have a lot of good tone in my legs because again, I used to stand and walk and run a lot.
Thoughts on soy milk. I don't like soy milk.
I prefer oat milk over everything though.
Oat milk almond milk has a texture of like spit to me.
Like I don't know how to explain it.
Same thing with eggnog.
Like I can't drink eggnog because it tastes like I'm drinking spit and not even like the fun time kind, you know.
Yeah, I could make my own uncrustables.
Because then I can use gluten free bread.
Actually, I might do that.
I like like slightly sweetened.
Get a massage my leggies.
That'd be nice.
My legs actually don't hurt too much.
It's usually my upper body hurts a lot.
Like my shoulders.
Like I had to stay in a long position at the doctor the other day with my arm out for like blood drawing and stuff.
And like my shoulder was killing me.
Like it was like like my body was just like not having a good time.
And you know, I want to be TMI for a second.
You guys know I got huge Bosonga hungas.
And I noticed well because I had to drive far away from my appointment.
I was like I had to like move like pull my booba towards the center of my chest so I could because I had was resting my my hand on my arm on top of it while I was driving on my my my left arm and I'm like I have to move it out of the way.
And and then like my bra was like stabbing my inner arm.
And I'm like, bro, this is annoying.
And I got to like mush them together so I don't like cut off circulation to my inner arms.
They're they're like they're very annoying and in the way.
How often is this oh all the time splits them like the Red Sea.
Voice Tonka trucks.
Yeah, they're annoying and in the way a lot and they cause me a lot of pain.
No, she don't get a reduction.
Oh, cry harder.
Cry harder.
She be you just have to do this.
No, you're shut up.
Shut shut shut shut shut shut.
I am a VTuber.
If I was like an only fans creator, then I would get it because like that's sad or whatever.
But like you guys don't understand the amount of pain I get in.
So I'm sorry, but not sorry.
Guys, I'm not cutting them off.
Guys, I told you I'm an F.
I just want to be like a double D again or like a D.
That's it.
That's all I want.
And that's like don't get me wrong like I love them.
I love them very much.
If I didn't have to reduce them because of the pain in my neck and shoulders and back and my lower back constantly, then I wouldn't.
And I've done I've been to physical therapy for three years and I did a lot of stuff to like strengthen my back and my neck and all that stuff.
But it's just brother.
Yeah, I'm just guys.
I'm not getting like top surgery.
Why she's going to be cute.
Frontier.
What if you don't like the complications from the surgery?
You have the body of Victorian girl.
It's not really that bad.
I've seen I've seen what's it called just like this the surgery before because I'm weird and like to do that stuff.
So they're going to be redo.
What if I just stick it in my butt?
Then I have a strong but no, I'm not getting a guy's that's not how reductions work.
You can only reduce so much safely.
I can probably at most go down to a C safely.
And that's you can Google what those sizes are.
I know you're you're a guy.
You don't even know what I'm talking about.
Go Google the sizes.
Go Google the sizes right now.
And then you'll be like, oh wait, she'll still have big boot like relax.
Yeah, it'd be a lot of scarring and complications if I were to attempt to go to an A cup.
Okay, we're having a we're having a chat right now.
Boob cup size images.
Can I get a can I get a bra?
Where's the where's the bra?
Okay, this is actually a perfect picture.
YouTube this is educational relax YouTube relax.
It's educational.
I'm educating men on sizes.
Save.
Will this work?
Or the Chaco?
This is just the best bra for whatever.
But I'm just using this as an example.
Images.
Hope is downloaded properly.
Perfect.
These lovely women will help me.
So I am you see the double D.
I am past that.
I just want to go to a C.
I'm an F.
Notice.
Like you see you see the girl with the B body type.
I have her body type but I have those.
It's not a fun time.
I just want to see.
It's all I want.
I can show you the world.
Milk is kind of what bro.
I think you're I think you're far too back in the conversation.
He's talking about the milk still.
Yeah.
No, they're they're bigger.
Let me see if I'll find you F size F.
Where is F F.
Oh my God.
It's literally.
Yep.
That this looks kind of bad, but it's fine.
This this is F.
But I have a body type.
That's a lot smaller.
My back hurts.
Okay.
You're never it's not like it was funny.
I'm sorry.
I said she was like, you know, you should start bartending.
And I'm like, what, why?
She's like, see if you get more tips with larger boobs.
And then if you ever decide to get a reduction, see if the tips
change.
I'm like, you foul for that.
Um.
Yeah.
Top heavy, Top heavy.
And again, my bras caught and you're like, oh, you can change the bra
Yes, I have I can wear a sports bra still hurts. I wear a normal bra straps still hurt where
Seamless bras they still hurt
everything hurts
Constantly if I didn't have fibro, I'd probably be fine, but I have fibro so I will
Goodbye
How would she be streamed she's currently trying to justify getting a reduction to her male fan base who are screaming
No, although she's a vtuber and they'll never really see her boobs except very very rarely
Have you tried all of them at once
No bra. Yeah, no bra hurts because like my skin is being pulled down because they're so heavy
And again, it causes it causes
Like stretch marks and stuff
Yeah, you guys can you guys please hold these hold these because honestly holding them is
probably like the best
because
Like if I rest them on the table
If I rest them on the table
It feels the best because there's no stress on my shoulder
And there's no stress on stress on my back and I feel so weightless it is the funniest thing I
Feel so weightless and then when I sit up. I'm like wow. I just gained like 50 pounds
And you know sleeping I'm sorry, I'm going to rant about this right now sleeping I
Can't sleep on my stomach. I
Can barely sleep on my side when I sleep on my side my arm goes numb because the weight on my titty
How it rests I gotta tuck up tuck around
It cuts off circulation to my arm and my arms wake up numb
Is the physical exercise. Yes, I've done that when I was in physical therapy
Um
It was funny when I first went to apply for coverage for reduction because you have to like do that for americans
the
The male
Um
Surgeon general who was looking at my claim for the insurance
said
Because you don't have a rash under your boobs. You're fine and I'm like
I'm sorry. I clean under my boobs. Like it was a am I supposed to let the like that just all the titty sweat
Just rot and like work away my flesh and just fall off the bone
I'm sorry. I clean myself. I don't know what to tell you. I still I still permanent bruising on my shoulders from straps, so
What do I think of four? Where did you come from with this question? What do I think of four?
What are you doing here? We're talking about boobs
What bone I don't know my ribs
My rib cage where they rest on they rest on my rib cage
I know you're a man, but catch up, please
Time in the place, dude
I
Mistake you what you're three months too late, baby girl. What do you do?
I meant to ask it there, okay
I'm so sorry. That's just too funny to me. Boomie. What are you doing?
Uh, oh, no, you're fine. No, no, no, you're fine. You're fine. Don't worry. I'm not like mad at you or anything
Neither is my chat. We just think you're really funny because it just came out of nowhere. That's it. That's the reason why
Oh, that was funny
Thank you for the lab
Oh
This is a tiger. Yeah. Uh, all right fine. Let's go. You know what?
I
Wait, why is my
It's a chat with fia. Are you purring in your sleep?
Give me kisses
Okay, there's no chat
I don't know what happened to the chat widget
I think mercy was mentioning that I broke all the chat widgets like some sort of update on obs
All right, we're going to my bedroom
What are you talking about?
Good yawn
Whoa
Oh
Let me do this pop you out mama said pop you out. I'm gonna pop you out of the youtube chat
He is just quietly purring beside me and it's quite adorable
Chat summary viewers are jokingly discussing preferences for body types and preferences for adult activities involving those body types. What?
AI what are you talking about?
That's not what we're doing at all
We're talking about reductions. What are you? What do you want?
Oh my god
Oh
Yeah, that's uh, that's that's the last I'll speak of the reduction stuff because I know it
I send some of you guys into a tizzy
That uh, especially some of you just
Just don't want me to feel better
Oh my god
Am I a g because I don't look like that
That's 28 g looks more like myself than the 30 triple d
Sorry, I'm just looking at boobs now
Like bra sizes you to bra sizes
Make it into a swap. That's not how that works
Have you ever measured them? Uh, I have a measure I can measure them right now actually I have a chest
Because I got a measuring tape for my um
For for a dress
There's another
All right, I got the measuring tape
Yeah, I think I'm more of a maybe that's why my bras don't fit because I've been getting like f but I think it might be a g
All right, let me just
If you don't look at me while I do this
How do I
I
Can't this is hard I also have to tuck them under I have to tuck the tape under myself
I have to
Oh my god, this is so difficult I can't even like
I
Wait, nope, that's not accurate
Please
Guys I need help
This is difficult to try to measure across my chest
Guys help me
Okay, I think I got it
So yeah, I am 45 inches
from
Um like around
Actually
Yeah 45
That is my circumference
Um
And then I already told you guys I'm a 34 for my
What you're gonna call it
Thank you euro your own friend
Um and that yeah 34 yeah 34 33
Ass let me see I don't I don't really have one
I've told you guys this I blame my white mother
She
That's funny my ass is 42
Wait, hold on. Nope, that's incorrect. I was doing at the top of my waist. Hold on
It's actually 44
That's so weird
Oh
Yeah, you want to feels like looking at the measuring tape like can I play with them you want this what the measuring tape
Yeah, boomie helpings your pouch come here
Get over here handsome. I'm measuring your pouch
Come here. I'm gonna measure your pouch. Get back here. Get back here booby. I'm measuring your pouch
Booby is 19 inches around including pouch
Pouch
Booby is 19 inches including a pouch
Booby, why are you so big?
Yeah, did you hear him honk as he ran over?
He's not he's not fat. It's literally just his pouch if I did like his like
From just like his normal stomach like it would be way less
He just has a long pouch for some reason. I don't even know why because it's like
The primordial pouch is like a fat storage for like animals in case of like danger
And like rena doesn't really have too much of rena. Why are you giving me bombastic side eye right now?
man
And then fia has a tiny tiny one, but booby just has a big pouch
Right fia your brother had a big pouch. Come on here for the kisses
He's honked. What's he driving? An accord. I offer you an accord
A Honda accord
Rise tarnished
And drive your spectral steed
How big are rings rings?
Uh, I don't actually know I do have a ring sizer
Is that a six? No wait
Six
Boomi are you trying to take boomi I'm gonna I'm gonna size your pouch again
Actually, no, I just use I just use the thing. I forgot I gave the ring sizer to my mom
Because I just never knew my ring size and I would go to buy myself rings
Boomi actually he's 20. He's 20
What?
No, wait, you're more than that because that's just around your stuff. Why are you so big?
Why are you trying to lay there? That's just a weird place for you to lay
Okay, let me move my keyboard and you can chill out. There you go. See are you comfy?
I'm so sorry boomi it's laid on my toggles again
Hail hail hail
Hail
Chat summary viewers are commenting on a stream where a person named boomi is being measured by wait. No, where did it go?
I want to take a screenshot of that
Dang it. If I refresh it, it will come back
Come on give me the auto generated
Is being measured by another person named sheebie without his consent
Viewers are outraged by this invasion and privacy are demanding that boomi take legal action against sheebie
I need a screenshot of that
I need to just refresh it and screenshot it
Oh my god, this is
Oh, aren't you funny
Boomi's lawyer tipped four dollars and 20 cents
Sheebie, thank you for the further proof of your harassment against my client breaking hepa stalking molesting his pouch. Good day, madam. Good day
Boomi
What are you cooling about?
We stay on boomi
Oh my god
Oh my gosh, what time is it? It's 10 30
He just came over smacked my foot and ran away
Is this the man you you you stay you stand for a man that just batters innocent women
Oh
What is h pass or ass
Let me let me do my thigh
Wait
I got thick um thighs
I got I got strong
strong hamstrings
My thighs are as almost as uh boomi is as almost as big as my thighs
Can't tell if that's oh wait though this is twisted let me fix that
24 thigh she be look at the ai let me look
Viewers are joking with she be about proposing marriage to them and are discussing her recent weight gain
My recent weight
Uh
We're talking wait, let me let me do my waist
I got thick thighs bro. I've always had thick thighs even when I was super super super skinny
Now I'm just like average to be honest with you
I can't I honestly I don't think I can check the size of my waist because I can't see past my boobs
Oh my god, I literally can't what number is that?
I can't see it
This is so hard
Oh
Like third weight
28 29
I can't
I can't tell
I don't know it's in the 20s. That's not a lot. I don't have a 20 inch waist. That would be insane. Um
But it's less than my chest
That sounds ridiculous. I've never actually like done my own measurements before
I
Do got the curves from my from my dad said I got the curves my daddy said
The plank ass I got from my mom said although my mom is a fat butt now, but I think that's just her age
I
My foot size I have big feet
I have big feet because I'm tall
The gambit accent, whoo, but I'm making a living from myself out here
Um, yeah my size uh nine
Nine and a half. Yeah
Yeah, my mom's way my dad's way
So I got big boots to step on
I wear a oh lordy. Give me the vapors with that accent. Um
I wear a men's 10
If you're most dudes have like size like 13 what's wrong with y'all
You
That's ridiculous
Where men's 16 men's 10 is still big see I told you I got big feet
I don't have small dainty feet. I'm sorry my mom is cute small dainty feet. She's a size eight
She had like it's funny because um
My mom used to wear like a lot a lot of high heel shoes and platform shoes because she was like it worked in an office
And my mom had like my mom has some nice feet
Oh my my dad lucky. He got a woman with nice feet
But I was so frustrated because I never fit into my mom's really nice high heeled shoes
So I couldn't inherit them because she has some she got some nice ass shoes
Maybe I'll steal them and sell them on the internet
Oh
Share with the I'm not exposing my mom's feet on here
Yeah, I'm I'm uh, I'll wear yeah, and I wear like a 10 and doc martins I I like um
My my shoe of the fall or my my jade and doc martins
um
My co-workers used to call them my shit kickers
And I would be much much taller than my my customers when I wore them
She went to sleep her child with the high heels
My mother my mother never busted out the shanka because again, she's a she's a white woman. So, um
She mostly just like grabbed me by the ear and she was like
What are you doing?
What do you think about ugg boots? Uh
They were cooler like 10 years ago
Honestly, I just wear crocs and docks
That rhymes um
Yes, I'm about like six feet in heels. So, uh
Yeah, the women's is 8.5. Yeah
Yeah, I'm I'm a 9.5
But I like I fluctuate because sometimes there'll be a nine sometimes there'll be a 9.5
Sometimes there'll be a 10 depending on the shoe
I like high tops I prefer high tops like I used to have I always wore high top converse
um, I have high top canvas doc martins because I used to make those I got those off of um
uh posh mark
um
Yeah, I have uh
What are those I have these hiking shoes
that I really fought like
ran over the place for because I my feet are very particular because one of my uh, my right ankle gets inflamed really easily. Um
It will also just roll really easily. I don't know why
My right ankle is like that. Um
Um, but so I have to have something with really good ankle support when I go hiking and um
What did I I got my support and I forget I don't even know those those are on bro. I'm so sure
It's okay king. It's okay. Don't you worry. You're fine. You're fine
We stand short kings we stand tall kings
We stand big
Muscular we stand the the skinny and lean. We stand the the fluffy boys up in here
Our anchor to the river you get literally though
I remember I I always have people come up to be like you ball you ball you must ball you must ball and I'm like
No, I like anime and I like reading books. I don't like um
I don't like do sports
But I'm five six and he leaves
But injuries are pretty bad as young as six kids. Oh gosh
dang the stinks
This is perfect boys
And it's funny because my dad used to coach
so I was just like
People were so disappointed that I couldn't play basketball
Be like your dad
Watching eSports at all recently got into anime. No, I don't watch any sports
The only sports I was watching is sports
um
And it's funny like my dad worked with a lot of
Uh, well not a lot of a few famous basketballers who have gotten into the NBA. He mentored them. He helped them
um
And like then there's me just who can't play as basketball
Can't play basketball. Yeah, my dad did that as a side job for a bit
Uh
There we go
Don't worry about that
Might just work my controller on accident. I didn't even smash it this time. Did I break it?
Oh, she's gone. Oh, no
No, I didn't even break it on purpose
It has knocked it off my desk
Come back to life come back to me
Please
No
How did this break it didn't even fall from up high like high
Oh my god
Well guys, I'm gonna add another controller to throne another controller my first controller
damn
Are you serious?
You know, it was like this one was red like like me like it like it fit me perfectly like my like
It was red and black my my playstation controller. It was like a maroon red
Uh playstation 5. I don't know. I just dropped it doesn't even have any cracks. It won't turn on
Something must have gotten like undone like came on like on
Wait, I'm coming undone
So I'm assuming something got like messed up, but it like dropped this one time
I'm trying to figure out how to open it because now I just fixed it myself, but I can't open this
There must be a tool you need
Oh, hello, I just broke my controller
Hi
We're getting raided. We got we got we're getting re-rated
Because stronti raided us earlier and then we weren't even screaming
I dropped my controller and I broke it. So, uh
I didn't even rage it literally just fell off of my desk because I've nudged it
I'm very sad
I like this controller a lot I do have that I do have some pc tools
Oh, sorry for you. I don't mean to bang on the desk. No, I literally just I literally bumped you with my hand
It was on the corner of my desk. Well, I'll say I'll put this off to the side
Um, so if I do rage at a game I can smash that controller instead
Blame it. Yeah, it's probably boomies fault. I blame boomie
But how you guys doing reflames? How you doing? Hello? It's me. She me cotton bum
Yes, you already know who I am. I don't think I have to elaborate
Yeah, I don't I don't understand because the blue light's not coming on. It's fully charged. I was playing with it like a second ago
Uh, do we have maybe I can ask my dad for a controller?
Because my dad has a ps5
Because I have games to play that require a controller
It literally dropped from like hold on where did the little
Where did the I know I put the the um
It was like a boomie and a half pouch away from the ground. It was probably like 30 inches
Micro celebrity, I'm a niche internet celebrity. My name is she be cotton bum and you're watching
Fielder's genuine indulge
Boomi pouch is a new even in a better minute
Did the battery fall out? What do you mean? It's it's wireless. There's no bat. There's no battery
It's a ps5 controller
I plugged it in let me try to plug it in a different one
This is not a cop. Don't don't come for me like that
Hit the oh true. Yeah, there's a hole in the back. I don't think I have anything to poke it
You good buddy
Let me focus into another spot
I swear I've had two controllers. I might have another controller
Now she gone she gone gone, okay, drop it again
I'm gonna bounce back and play
He's like, what the heck are you doing? Throw in my controller
Work
You
Wait, I should probably stop doing this because of my neighbor
I
Okay, she's gone
She's gone folks. She's never coming back. Oh, thank you for the 10 gifted right coma. Thank you. Thank you
You thank you so much. This is that is some solace in this dark time
Some some some solace some solace
James Bond solace solace
Uh, yeah controller repair stream
Percussive maintenance. There's tools. No, no
Yeah, how you doing? How you doing?
That's good, it is an average game for your
Yeah, well, I was gaming I was I streamed for like, uh, like three hours more like two
Oh my god, I was this asphodel like the like the game
My experience placing controllers break more easily than a tiny little mechanical pencils
Um
I would have played for longer because I wanted to chat a bit and then play some more
So never mind
I'm not playing with keyboard
Well, I don't have an x I used to have an xbox
Yeah, I generally don't know how it broke
Okay, there's no like physical damage on it. Is there anything
I
Sorry, I'm shaking it to hear if there's anything like loosen it
There's nothing loose in it
No, they're like 60 there's like 60 bucks
I'll just buy another there's a game stop
Uh somewhere
So I'll just I'll just buy
Well, there's nothing loose in it. Yeah, can you hold on to this for me? You want to snuggle with the controller?
Here, yeah, you can use it as a pillow
She's just like I just like put her arms around it. She's like what's happening
Can I get a kiss? Oh, thank you for the kiss
Can I get a nose kiss?
Oh, thank you for the nose kiss sometimes fia, um, will wake me up by licking my nose
And so she gave me a little nose in your nose lick
Fia's playing the game
Imagine imagine fia fixes it
That's so wild to me. I literally it didn't drop from like a big height
Oh my god
Marina you're
peeing so loud
You literally jump scared me with your pee
My god, woman
It's close in your country better cat nose than a 45
That's funny like you guys
Like looks your chin that's cute
Yeah, it's cute cuddles will fix
Yeah, fia use your cuddle powers to fix it little girl
Yeah, that's what I mean. Yeah, I'm like some that's I just probably just fell just the right way and just something
Got messed up in there. I probably just like bent out of shape or just like was jostled off of something
Um, because this doesn't sound like there's anything loose in there, but
Oh my god
Thank you for the the super by the way said
Yeah, they shut down gamer former I was like wow
I told you guys I used to work our game stop, right?
That was that was a time one of my first jobs
And uh, it was very funny
Good night. Have a good one. Thank you for stopping by and giving me a chance
And I'm going to jump into me
They didn't even archive it
That's so weird
Because I saw that they got rid of it, but I'm like, okay
Damn
I already gave it forward a couple times
And then again, I had to sell it
The booty lord
Why do you guys have the names that you have? Have a good night
Have a good night everybody
Have a good night reflins sweet dreams reflins dream of mome
Oh dang it's gone
Oh
Raina you just pee and let everybody know just screaming
Raina just peed and it was just was like I peed
I peed check the AI, okay
What do you gotta say why am I getting a mere lax ad?
What it won't it's not loading the AI
Here feel let me help you
I need to get like eye drops for you because you've been sleeping with your eyes open
Okay, the AI isn't coming up. So I guess I will never know I am forbidden. Let me turn off Hades
Wait
Oh, yeah, no progress saved 108 minutes ago
Yeah, I'll try to swing by I won't make you guys pay for that actually. I don't I feel I would feel bad
Now that I think of it
I don't want
You guys to think I see you. I was just like, oh something's broken. Just add it to throne
Okay, I'm gonna buy it for me
Oh usually the AI summaries at the top of the chat like not like like scroll all the way up
But usually just like hang it out for a little bit then it'll go away. That's what we're here for
No, you think you're here just to give me stuff
No, you're here because I want attention
This is what
I don't have you as my audience because I'm trying to as uh someone is so
Funnily joking about
Um, I'm not here to rinse your pockets kid
I'm here to make memes and laugh and become a niche internet celebrity like I've always wanted because I like attention
So we're here for the cats. Yeah, you're here for the cats
I'm a very lonely person. I need attention
Because you guys like I did well paying job before I left it like
I was I was fine like
I wasn't just like, you know, I'm doing this for them. No
Doing this because I I I was very very depressed and um
I needed I realized I needed a creative outlet. So I started streaming as a vtuber
um, and it was
Absolutely amazing for me. Like a lot of people saw a change in me
Because I was being a lot more creative like designing stuff spending time with new people
It was really cool. Um, and so I'm happy I can still have that
This is definitely a better job
Obviously the dummy mommy sad girl hours, you know, it was like really hard
Having to go to the office all the time
Sorry for you
Oh
It's okay. Yeah, I'm not I can make you feel better
You build gumplug. Yeah, like so everybody has a thing that they do
To make themselves feel better
Oh my god, I'm saving so much money not driving so much money
Yes, I spent you spent so much money on starbucks
So much money on starbucks bad
Starbucks is so expensive expensive. I can't talk today
Jorkin makes me
You know what
You know that one gif of that lady who has like takes her glasses off or she adjusts them and she just like spreads her arms
It's like, well, yeah, that's what that's what we're here for like, you know
Welcome fellow coomer, you know, what can I say?
Sometimes you just got to jork it jorker peanuts
He's gripping it
What wait, hold on a second
Gas has been insane the first assignment farting, um, but yes the prices of gas have been
Astronomical got a willy the wonka
Got a shibbity my cotton bum
got a
Shib
I'm getting so many ads on my own freaking stream stop
I uh, I have a cover-up toggle
But I
I don't know if it's actually on this model if it's on the way still I should probably at strawney. Are you still here?
She's probably asleep
She probably knocked out
What time is it an upside down land? I don't even know
Does she need to flee? What do you mean?
She be fy do be do be do
She not even mom is in the bath. Mommy. I'm going to message you
I
Hi, are you diddling yourself in the bath?
Hello, JK.
Anyways, have you learned about my coverup toggle progress?
She's not my boss, she's not my boss, she's my friend.
I don't see, I don't see Strania's boss, well like, obviously, you know, she has the
last say in things, but I don't see her like, she's my boss, I better read that as no, no,
she's my, she's like my co-worker, she's my friend.
I knew, yeah, she's, she's my boss bestie.
Our cohort.
She's taking it straight on the way, my god.
You like our dynamic?
Yeah, we all got a cool dynamic.
Yeah, she actually doesn't see stuff, well no, that's the investor, Strania's different,
other different people.
What do you mean?
Again, like, I, I think what makes me different from, because like, I had a good relationship
with my bosses at my last job, like, we're all very like, chill, and so I think it's
a little bit easier for me to be that way with Strania, it might be difficult for the
other girls, because they're like, pretty, like, I sometimes still get, oh my god, boomie,
harassing Reina.
Boomie.
Reina, are you okay?
You good?
Vigorously lick self.
And I think like, if you've been used to having like crappy bosses, it's hard to like, be
vulnerable and open yourself up to them.
But she does a great job, I'm very proud of her, she's also growing a lot too, like she
takes a lot of feedback really well, like, if she's like, should I do this?
I'm like, well, this could happen, or this could happen.
And she's like, thank you for your advice, you beat.
And I'm like, anytime, because just like my lore, it's pretty accurate.
I used to work in a very corporate environment, really big execs of a really big, huge company.
So I'm very used to, if you're used to that, having that sort of professionalism, but also
like maintaining friendships.
Change of time as a V-Lir company goes public.
I don't really think that'll be a thing.
Like, we're a small agency.
I don't think we're going to be like, hollow or needy, where you can like, buy stuff.
Because like, I don't think any is idol publicly traded, was it?
Oh, boomie, stop.
You're done, bro.
You're literally scared, Reina, all the way to my desk.
Are you OK?
You OK, my mish?
It's OK, Reina, you can hang out.
He's literally just like, try to reach up and like, bap her.
Yeah, we haven't been growing really well.
Mom, yeah, you guys hear like, the sternness in my voice.
Did you just hear that?
Boomie, do you have the zoomies?
I gave you a toy.
Reina's staring at my model.
Idol was bought by Globy.
You mean by Brave Group, who owns Globy?
Yeah, I don't think that'll be a thing.
I don't think we'll ever grow that much.
And I kind of hope, I don't think Strani would want us to grow that much.
And I wouldn't want us to grow that much.
I like, just being like, small to medium sized.
Like, if I like, 50,000 people watching me, wait, no,
how many people do they have watching them most of the time?
The hollow girls, I don't even know.
Like, 20k.
I don't know if I would survive.
That's a big chat.
I pride myself on my chat interaction.
I was freaking out when I had, like, 6k on the debut.
I was like, wah!
The most people I'd ever streamed to in my lifetime was 400 before that,
when I got rated by someone on Twitch.
Yeah, JP is like 50k.
Yeah.
I like, I find, like, I obviously can't control it.
Like, how we grow as a community and as a company,
in terms of, like, our concurrent viewership and stuff.
But I would prefer to be smaller.
I like how you spelled that J-Pan.
Oh, Narissa's 3D debuts today?
I thought it was, um, tomorrow.
Cause, like, again, time zones.
Dang it.
I'm missing the debuts.
Yeah, I like, smelled it.
No, why would I ever forget you guys?
No, don't say that.
I'm not gonna forget you guys.
I know, like, some of you guys are like,
I wanna gatekeep because they'll real forget us
and you're totally entitled to that, to have that opinion.
Totally entitled to that.
But don't think I'll ever, like, forget you guys.
Like, I'll still see people in my PL
and I'll be, like, who, like, just stop by to see how I'm doing.
Like, I might not be their cup of tea now,
if because, like, I was very, like, I wasn't very,
but, like, I would say so.
Um, and it's always nice to see their faces.
It's like, oh, like, a passing old friend, you know?
But you guys, you guys will always be there,
so you will not be an old friend.
You'll be a current friend.
I have to toot.
Damn.
Say so? Yeah.
Pretty say so.
I was pretty...
People forget that I was cute and funny
and very say so.
I would, like, swear, but otherwise,
I didn't really do anything else.
I thought they were lewd.
I know, some people thought I'd be like,
oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
No, I'm not doing that.
Okay, keep me the farzer of 20k viewers?
I don't know about that.
I'm pretty sure Strani's got, like, a short of me
farting, cooking.
Cooking in the editor's room.
I don't even have 1k of those people.
What, 1k of people wanting me to fart?
I don't...
Mer...
Well, again, as Rina,
I literally had a non-outfit.
And I was a Siamese cat priestess.
The worst I got was towards the end
when I was about to graduate.
And because Strani had already sent me my 3DO.
And so I was using it on stream
and I was, like, just testing the waters
about how lewd I could be.
And I'm like, I'm too...
It was too powerful.
And non-outfitters.
No, I didn't get... What?
Guys, it was on Twitch.
It was on Twitch!
No, I'll probably not be the non again.
You probably won't be CBB for a very, very, very long time.
Why are you guys looking at me like that?
House of Purple. Yes, the House of Purple.
Sorry, I was calling it, like, instead of, like, red, like, Vermillion.
Wait, is Vermillion green or red?
Never get.
House of Azure.
Azure. Azure.
House of Indigo.
Indigo is more like, purpley.
I always thought Indigo was blue,
but I've been told it's actually purple.
What, you are on Twitch?
Yes.
Again, as you have seen from...
And I've said my past life so many times.
And people are like, wait, wait.
But I was a nobody. I literally streamed to, like, 20 people.
I had less than 1,000 followers.
I think I was at, like, 800 or...
I was, like, going to 900.
Rena, no.
Your favorite...
Hi, everybody.
I kind of wish you could have heard those...
Well, sorry.
You got something better instead.
Oh, no, not recently.
No, no, no, I'm at my past life.
The voice sounds like it hurts to do.
It doesn't, actually.
I can maintain the higher pitch voice pretty, pretty well,
because I would do it for hours.
That's why people didn't know that I was...
Like, people thought I was either going to be Emmy or IC.
Because, like, I had a lot of fun during my streams,
is I would use my really high-pitched voice and talk like this,
and then I would switch and drop to the mommy voice
and be like, hey.
And then people would be like, oh, my God, what?
What?
Mommy voice?
But, yeah.
Yeah, I'm just being me.
Although, I still, again, I've said...
I do the opposite facts.
I always say that, like, me and Rena are two sides of the same coin.
Like, she's my more childish side,
and she in, like, when I...
Like, I was way more childish as Rena,
and more say-so and more, like...
I don't know.
Yeah, and then, like, she's kind of like the other side of the coin.
You personally have pins, will you?
Yeah.
A lot of people thought I was going to be Emmy.
A lot of people didn't know it was me,
and when they watched me, they're like, that's not her.
Until I actually came out and said it.
People were like, nah, nah, nah, that's not her.
She has to be Emmy, and I'm like...
Emmy just said she was Liberty, so...
What are you guys talking about?
Um...
Because, again, my voice range...
A bunny smooch?
What gives you the right to think you can come in here
and ask for a smooch, sir?
We just met. I'm a lady.
All right, you don't get to waltz up in here
and be like, can I get a bunny smooch?
No, huh?
Mm-mm.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, Muppet Sheeby make a comeback in a whole new way.
You don't even know yet.
Yeah, everybody, harem, you can smooch.
Everybody kiss him.
Harem, mods, kiss that man.
Doing funny voice to friends.
Frankly, that was fun.
It was really fun.
Can we get some smooches?
Uh, no.
Why do you guys think you can get smooches?
What do you...
You guys are making demands of your madam.
Yeah, everybody, smell check.
I used to have what I wish YouTube had
and I hope they eventually put in
is like how there's like channel point stuff
because I would have channel points
for people who would like redeem stuff
and they'd be like, they would dream like an R-R-R.
So I'd be like, hi, everybody.
Oh, look, an R-R-R.
Okay.
And they'd be like...
Or I'd be like...
All right, hey, we're doing this today, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh, somebody redeemed an oo-oo.
Oo-oo?
And then I would also have the burp donation.
So if I burped, I would donate it
or would dedicate it to somebody.
Yeah, my R-R-R and that one...
What's it called?
That one short was very lackluster.
A lot of my old content was very lackluster
because I was new to everything and I was very shy.
What do you call the channel points though?
What?
They just call channel points, I don't know.
What's channel points?
Burps and wraps.
Call me male, neck and neck.
No.
Sorry, I make that...
That's like the second time I've made that joke.
I'm sorry.
If you know, you know.
I'm not her.
I'm holding up my hand.
It's just a running joke
because they're a horrible person.
I wasn't gonna say.
Can you say that oo-oo again?
No.
There you go.
I believe they applied to Veeler too
and I'm just like,
thank god they did not get in.
If they did, I don't know if they did.
Maybe last year.
I got that bass in my chest.
That's actually hard.
Redeeming a burp dedication?
I don't know if I'm gonna burp.
She got the homie in it.
I got that brother in me.
That sounds bad.
God damn it, she beat me.
Stop.
Put the mouse away.
Enough.
Don't do that.
Don't make it weird.
Stop, bro.
Stop.
I wish I had a brother in me.
I'll put a brother in you.
Yeah.
It's just Shabrowski.
What the heck is on the-
What is that?
What is this?
Oh, it's a kernel.
Okay, I got really nervous.
Sorry, something was like wet on the bottom of my
gamer sub's cup and I was like freaking out
because I didn't know what it was.
Stop laughing.
Shut up.
All of you, be quiet.
Hush your mouths.
He goes, let me check the oven.
They cut away your brother.
What?
Yeah, quiet, quiet, quiet.
Get stepped on, get stepped on,
get stepped on, get stepped on.
Punch the mic.
Hey, Shibi, where could one get a gamer sub's cup?
We're 10% off.
You can get your very own gamer sub's cup
with Coach Shibi.
Oh my God.
I'm not chilling.
This is part of my job.
I am a-
This is their spot.
I don't know what you expect me to do.
Jesus Christ.
You're a link.
There's a limp-
A limp?
I'll link in the description.
I'm just stepping on you, like just picture me,
just like stomping on your face and going,
uh, buy gamer sub's merch.
Buy gamer sub's cups.
Buy it all with Coach Shibi,
or you will be gone from this earth.
You will no longer exist.
I just like looking at your guys reactions.
This is funny.
What's the description?
It's in my YouTube description.
Yeah, yeah, you know,
I'm gonna fendom you with my sponsorships.
Go.
Now.
For all of us, actually.
Cause then we can get a cup.
Or a flavor.
Imagine a veal-
Or the vealer gamer sub's flavor be.
I'm currently drinking the peach lemonade flavor lean.
The tracking is so funny.
Cause you can literally see me drinking.
Fruit punch the mic.
That would be my personal flavors.
Stop drinking me.
I haven't tried anime thighs yet.
Vealer be a lemonade flavor.
I feel like strawberry lemonade.
Shibi flavor.
Peeler.
That's what the name of it would be called.
Anime thighs like orange creamsicle.
Peeler.
Yeah, are you still purring in your sleep?
She'll like stop and then she'll just like look at me
and purr and then fall asleep.
Oh little girl, you're so tired.
I know I can tell.
PB&J and apple juice.
That sounds disgusting as a flavor.
For a drink?
Reina's laying on my keyboard.
I've never really done traditional tabletop stuff.
Hi Shibi.
I'd like to thank you for being an inspiration.
As a result, I've started doming people in the Vealer community discord.
I learned a little bit.
One, I'm a terrible person to learn from.
Two, Reina's still laying on my keyboard.
Three, why are you doming people in the discord?
Is that an actual thing?
What?
Y'all, what are you?
I don't even want to know.
I don't even want to do good.
So like again, we don't get to see the channel.
We can't go into it or anything, the channels or the discord.
Is there like different channels for each talent?
Is there, is this word?
And it's like the Shibi channel.
You guys are just doming each other.
Do you guys like this talk amongst?
I thought it was only for announcements.
Mercy's chat is popping.
That's good.
There's a media channel for images.
You guys better be posting memes in there of me.
Oh, this is the unofficial community one.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
It's a fan discord.
Got you.
Are you guys, are you guys grooming each other?
Please don't groom each other in the discord.
You have a, you have a Shibi Pat channel.
That's kind of cute.
This is a dedicated Shibi Pat channel.
It's just gifts of me being having the head pat.
No, no, only we're supposed to be the grooming.
You guys can't groom amongst yourselves.
I'm a very, I'm a jealous dom.
Fia, why are you looking at your paws so loudly?
What else is there to do in discord?
I don't know.
Talk about how awesome we are.
Well, Fia, they're so great.
I watched a stream from Mercy the other day
and I was laughing so hard.
Oh, well, that's awesome.
I was watching this stream from Icy
and I have such a good time being cozy with her playing brats.
Well, Stronny's my Oshi.
I was hanging out with her when she was playing
insert some game here that she needs to be carried in.
And then et cetera, et cetera for the other girls.
She actually watches the streams.
No way. Of course I watch the streams.
Well, I watched Shibi stream
and she measured her cat's pouch.
Wow.
Are you doing that a lot on Twitter?
I don't know. Do you? No.
Oh my god, have we groomed you to go only like us
and nobody else?
You are ours now.
They were stalker twitters?
Yeah, of course.
I usually look at like a lot of people who follow me.
I'll like say, it looks there at their Twitter for a bit
and I'll be like, hmm, what do you retweet?
Oh, I see.
Yes.
You guys thought that like it was only Emmy and Mercy
and maybe I see doing that.
Nah, bro, I'm there too.
Hi, CB.
I'm back from touching grass.
Glad to see you're still here.
Yes, hello.
Also, some of you guys have different names
to than your YouTube handles.
Like, I don't really know who's who
because you guys all have alts
because you're ashamed to love us, but it's fine.
We're side, oh, she's, it's fine.
Whatever.
Horses.
What are you doing, boomi?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tell it to the judge.
Yeah, exactly, skill issue.
Let's see what YouTube would have me
let more than two emojis.
That's one membership emotes are for.
Well, you probably, why does a different language join
when they not read it?
Google translate exists, buddy.
Okay, if you're on main, you're a real one.
If you have an alt, you will pussy, pussy bitch.
So I'm gonna say, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
I need to fix that color on my cheek.
I don't know why it looks like that.
I'll do that another time.
Guess I'm a real one then.
No, it's for me.
I think it's funny.
I've seen people say like, I have to go on an alt
cause one of my Oshie sees, sees me in another chat.
And I'm like, damn, you cheating on your wife with me?
Yikes, bro.
That one gray harlot.
I thought that said something else.
I thought I said that one gay harlot.
And I'm like, you know what, speak your truth, bro.
I appreciate you.
Welcome back.
You're so real for that, bro.
Thank you.
That would be so funny though.
Booby, what are you doing?
Why are you trying to shove yourself under the couch?
I remember someone sitting in the middle of a wheeler.
I remember the dudes going in the brothel behind the pipes back.
Oh, God.
I'm totally main account.
Oh, yes, of course.
I lost my shoe and my foot stool.
I don't know where they went.
The new mascots are back.
I'm not sure where they went.
The new mascots are Boomi and Reina's lawyers.
Boomi's so delectable.
Boomi, don't try to hit her.
He literally just put his paws on the edge of my desk
because he's tall and he tried to smack Reina.
Don't worry, Reina, it's just me.
I'm just tucking in your tail.
I don't even know how this is comfortable for you.
She's laying on my GoXLR and my keyboard.
I swear, you see the shoe once in a blue moon.
Wasn't there a Count Calcibi's blog?
Was there?
Maybe.
Honestly, I believe people just change their names
for the memes and then they change it back later.
And so they're probably still around.
They're just like under their normal names.
Trying to think, what else should I address in this stream?
You're all cowards and bastards.
I have cotton puffs for hands and I can choose to have knives.
Instead, what am I?
The cat answers cats.
At least you want to let me think about it for a moment.
Wasn't there a Shibikar?
Why would there be a Shibikar?
She lays the swap between accounts.
Yeah, I have an alt.
I creep on it.
I creep on you guys with, yeah, mm-hmm, yeah.
So you can write, what?
Do you have a car?
Yeah, what do I see?
I don't know what to tell you, man.
Hi, I'm Shibi's alt.
Just boy.
No, I've actually accidentally posted on my alt while streaming
when I like walked away to do something and I was like,
I forgot that I was logged into it and I was like, hey,
and then I'm like, ah!
Wait, I'm just like a random gray name.
I'm just like a random gray name.
Not that I meant, like it's not like nothing identifiable
is on it.
But, but yeah.
Yeah, nothing, nothing, nothing.
It's just, it's always an alt that I've had,
like a, like a, my YouTube account that I've had for years,
but I never, that I had made when I was like,
I don't know how.
Not even, why would I remember to myself?
Why would I remember myself?
I am doing the streams.
She could be any one of us.
Shibi's a gray name.
Gifted to yourself?
Yeah, I would just gift emotes
and then I would have to pay to do the thing.
Did you see my own members' streams?
I need to look at them back.
From the perspective of a member.
It's to be fair, Shibi, the value is quite good.
I would 100% agree with you.
Paying yourself?
Yeah, I'm just like, let me,
I'll write this off as an expense,
just like paying for my own membership.
Raina, why are you putting your toe out like that?
Damn, girl.
Why are you showing all that?
Look, I need to take a picture of Raina for you guys.
I'm gonna go, vent your little quest for a second.
Damn, girl, why are you sitting like that?
Why are you sitting like that with your leg out?
You guys ain't ready, she's showing some leg.
I'll post that after stream.
Yeah, I could be that one gray harlot right now.
You guys don't even know.
Infinite money glitch.
No, I was actually signed into the right account,
but I still couldn't see the members chat.
It was a weird glitch that day,
because it was, whoa, whoa, Raina,
you're messing up the view of my screen.
Viewers are joking about the streamer
possibly having multiple accounts being in her own chat.
They're also wondering, I will never know,
because they only have one account.
I will never know,
because they only show you it for five seconds,
the stupid thing.
Raina's making the thing zoom in out every time I scroll,
because she's laying on my keyboard.
No, no, the on-brand name would be,
would be that one gay harlot.
She views Boomi's lawyer, yeah, definitely.
Is her right?
The AI suspension is all, does it really?
What?
Yeah, I'm tired of Google.
I wish I could turn off the Google AI thing.
Raina, I can't get over your toes,
just being out like that.
It's so funny, the cats have four toes on their back paws,
but five toes on their front paws.
I don't know why that is.
Notice anything different?
Oh no.
No.
Playing among us on the couch, she views all.
Man, did you hear about the one cartilage
of the first on our class?
What are you talking about?
Except to this fate, that was pretty quick, I'm impressed.
I was, that was pretty quick.
Is the AI gonna say something about a gay harlot now?
Is that, is that what's gonna happen?
Can't change that for two weeks.
You're trapped.
Good thing it's your alt.
I would, it would just be like wild to me if like,
if like there's some like popular streamers or VTubers
out there that like make an alt to watch us.
And like, I could just have a straight up,
just like, all alive, member in my chat.
And I just don't know it.
I forgot to kick every two weeks.
Guys, I'm actually a little worried.
I will lose my mind.
Oh wait, that's, I'm not that, I didn't know who that was.
No, the chat is blue.
You're like, oh, I've heard of you.
I hope because.
I would, I would, yeah, I'd lose my mind.
I need to, I need to find more people to read too.
I need to, I realize I like was,
I watch a lot of YouTubers or I like,
at least I try to, I'll jump through chat to chat and all
and stuff and just kind of see the vibes.
And I was like, wait, why am I not subscribed to this person?
He'll tell.
No, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna raid hollow live.
Do you think I'm crazy?
I'm Yaku.
Yes.
No.
That one time I raided Pippa
because I didn't have anybody else.
I was feeling, I was feeling wild that day.
All right, thank you for the Tony gifted.
I don't think it's gonna hit that one girl.
Wait, did it?
Oh my God.
He got.
God.
Raiden, Arissa.
No, thank you.
I would, I would, I'm too shy.
Oh my God.
We broke the AI.
Hold on.
That is so funny to me.
Viewers are joking around about a streamer accidentally
changing his name to gay harlot
and speculating how hollow life would react
if he raided them.
Oh, thank you for the, thank you for the gifted.
Oh my God.
He got it.
That's so funny to me.
Tog, it's called Tog.
Togs.
Hi, Fia.
That is so funny that that happened.
Okay.
Let me find some peeps to raid.
Give me some suggestions of people I should follow.
La, la, la.
Wait, I'm going to subscribe to people after stream
because I don't like my name popping up.
I think I'm already subscribed to her.
Siren arrows.
I do not know who that is.
Where's Siren arrows from?
I already follow and subscribe to mutuals of mono.
I am shy.
Bob Ross is streaming?
No freaking way.
Haram, not harem, haram.
What you got to lose, Nini Amano?
No.
Oh my gosh.
I just didn't pass the stream in 12 hours.
Nini Amano, I would, I'm so scared about raiding people
who are like, I don't even know what to do with them.
I don't even know what to do with them.
I'm so scared about raiding people who are like very say so
because I don't want to like offend them
or like make their fan bases feel a certain way.
I am very, like, I try to be as respectful as possible.
Could be worse than do that toky clip too.
Cause I like, I get hurt very easily
when it comes to that sort of stuff.
Rage yourself, see you tomorrow.
Like, I don't worry about like the public's
negative opinion of me.
I worry about other agency vTubers
cause I'm trying to set a good example
that like Vee-ler is still a great company
despite the content that we make
cause people, you know, have negative stuff about that.
But, so I try to just be respectful
and respect people's, you know, space and stuff
if they don't want to interact with me
because of what I do.
But yeah, raiding into someone is a compliment.
Thank you.
I just, again, I'm, and then like my gen mates outfits
besides like Azura's are like probably,
they're pretty normal.
So like sometimes I get self conscious
cause my ball gag is out and it'd be like,
hi, I just raided you
and I'm just like funny dominatrix.
So like, that's why like on the stream of Para
cause I know she's just like,
hey, can we like do just like not anything sexual
for ASMR?
I'm like, I wasn't planning to, but okay.
I was wearing a different outfit
cause I wanted to make her feel comfortable.
Oh, or if I get written to my Christian VTB.
He's like, yeah, no, we haven't done anything bad.
It's like, it's not, I'm not saying like,
oh, we're doing bad things or whatever.
Or people probably don't think that we're bad.
It's just like they have this sort of standard.
And so I'm very cautious about interacting with people
cause I would hate for them to feel negatively
cause I struggle with, oh, Marina just set up my keyboard.
Oh, did you mute me?
No?
Okay, you're laying on everything.
Why'd you?
Sorry, I didn't mean to scare you.
I'm just moving cause you just opened audacity for no reason.
Cause again, like I don't see like collabing and stuff
as like business relationships.
I see them as like, if someone wants to collab with me,
like I only collab with people
that I want to form a friendship with.
I don't really care how big or small you are.
But if someone was just like,
just never wanted to talk to me again after a thing,
I'd be like, cause that is how I am.
Cause I want to be like, no, I'm a good person, but you can't.
Like you always have to remember,
you can't please everybody.
So, I miss Razzia.
Quick, Marina hit the torque taco.
Yeah, Amy's Razz got a strength.
I tried to be a sweetheart.
I tried to set a good example
cause I've had people say like they're intimidated by me
and that makes me very sad.
Cause I don't know how am I intimidating?
But then I guess, yeah.
And then a lot of people have like,
assumed that since I'm the Dom that like,
I'm just going to be a hard ass.
I am a sweet dork, but, you know, people,
people kind of form their own opinion and stuff
before they give me a chance.
So it makes me sad.
They're like, oh, she's a Dom.
Nah, dropped.
Oh, she dressed like this, nah, dropped.
Oh, she's like the, nah, dropped.
And I'm just like, get me a chance.
Let's talk to me, I'm pretty cool.
Yeah.
And so I try my best, but again,
the boomer is a plus.
She's a whore.
That like, oh my God.
What was it?
I remember my stream of para,
which I might upload to like,
if he is snoring,
I might upload to like, Fandly or something.
I don't know, or like, Patreon.
She's just, she's like, dead, like point blank ask me.
She's like, so how do your parents feel
about you being a whore?
And I'm just, and I just lost it
cause it was the funniest question I ever heard.
But like, but yeah, no, para told me she was just like,
you know, you're actually really cool.
Like I thought you were going to be a certain way,
like super sexual or super this or super that.
And it's funny because para knew me in my past lives,
but she, again, like when you take on a new IP,
you try to embody the character.
So I think she was worried I would have changed a little bit.
And then she's like, this is really awesome.
Like, I'm like, you're really cool.
And I'm like, thank you, I'm, yeah.
That was a funny collab.
Para had no filter,
but that's just her culture in the French.
Yeah, but she was, yeah,
she was, she was really fun to hang out with.
But yeah, I just, I just want people to find me approachable.
That's why, yeah, I was pretty say so.
And it's funny cause like, I would be very say so
in some streams, like Toma will all do me sometimes.
And you also want to self print before that.
And cause like, I choose my moments
and to like bring it out, you know?
You changed me, yeah.
Toma's so.
But like, yeah, I'm pretty, pretty normal.
Like I have my days.
And then I also just get worried about what I can
and cannot say on YouTube.
So I definitely like hold stuff in a lot.
Like if it was, if it was Twitch,
I probably wouldn't care as much or like kick.
Just Toma brought the shit puppet.
I'm just not surprised, but yeah.
Yeah, but I always say, hi streamer.
If you're a Vtuber who wants to collab with me
and you're interested in hanging out
with the girls from VLR, I do not bite.
I will respect you if you're say so.
I am very nice and sweet.
If you want to play a certain game, sure.
If you want to avoid certain games, sure.
If you want to do a certain topic, sure.
I will do whatever makes you feel comfortable
cause I'm just here to make friends
and make everybody happy.
So I hope you would consider collabing with me.
She be for president.
She be doing a short about that topic.
That'd be cool.
Kick is a danger.
Yeah, no, you will not catch me on kick.
I'll have a good night.
Bye bye.
Got my vote.
Yeah, that's true.
That's another reason why we're not on Twitch
is like sometimes you can just get banned for any reason.
But YouTube is like that now too.
Like Emmy could have just gotten her account removed
instead of getting a strike.
Just like some other VTubers I've seen,
they just have had their accounts just
yoinked off the face of the earth,
which is really sad.
So like strikes don't really mean anything anymore.
It's just warnings and they just tell you to keep off.
But they can just ban you for no reason
on YouTube and Twitch now.
Or like for made up reasons.
Like when your rats sniff into a mic, question mark.
Yeah, I've seen what happened with the VTuber clippers too,
which makes me really sad
because VTuber community thrives off of clipping channels.
Clipping is so integral to VTubing.
Like we would not have the audience that we do
without clippers.
When I say we, I mean like all VTubers.
Yeah, sniffing.
Yeah, that's the reason why.
Yeah, like I am like really sad
that Emmy can't stream right now.
Yeah, the shyly one.
But like that's with someone,
but that's cause possibly it could be the reason
because shyly has a lot of pull being large creator.
But like a smaller clipper channel
might not get that luxury, you know?
When this is like a fan clipping channel.
Wait.
Trani says I have my clothes shirt toggle.
What?
I don't, it must be, is the toggle hiding?
I did not see the toggle.
Hold on.
Hotkey action.
Yeah, no, it's not in there.
Let me look through the model files again
because that's so weird.
She said that the art, they sent it.
I don't think so.
Cause that would be a lot easier on me
and a manager who makes my thumbnails
cause we just have to smack like sensors over everything.
Cause I know the other girls,
I know like I think Mercy is getting one too
that we can toggle on and off.
Oops, that's not what I wanted to do.
Where is it?
Yeah, no, but it's not there.
Weird.
She is snoring is so cute.
I'm glad I got that email.
We are watching.
You may perceive.
Oh, I'm small.
Sometimes I like scroll wrong
cause I'm on the wrong page.
Okay, let me, I'm gonna find someone to read
cause I'm getting real hippie.
What's today?
Is Mercy streaming?
I don't know.
No, oh, Mercy's away.
That's right, she's on vacation.
Our discord has been really quiet
and I'm like bummed out cause everybody's busy.
Cause like, Amy's with her cousin.
Mercy's on vacation.
Azura's not feeling well.
So send Azura lots of love.
And then it's just me strutting and I see it.
I see it in a different time zone.
And so I'm just like, oh.
How could you remind the sun pies?
They were so pretty.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, sun pies.
She'll be back.
Slip, it's clutching me here right now.
All right, find me a person that's streaming right now
and I'll read them.
I'll do it.
Ooh.
Mama Monay, is she streaming?
No, she's not.
Rain is streaming.
I'm not gonna raid Mercy guys.
Do you want me to like explode?
You guys, no, I'm not.
Find a live bunny wildlife.
Yeah, with my 150, I'm gonna raid a 3D thing.
I don't even think I could.
Is it Cocone?
Why am I not?
There's so many B and U girls.
Just like so many, I can't keep track
of who I'm following and not following.
Like there's some people that I'm missing.
You all.
It says I'm subscribed, but I feel like I'm not.
What?
Thank you for the gifted.
I have an amphibian, what the heck?
All right, we'll raid Cocone.
It was really fun hanging out with her with the...
I wanted to raid somebody new.
It was fun hanging out with her with the Goose Goose Duck.
I can't get out of here.
All right, it's not letting me raid her.
What the heck, man?
Is it because I just subbed?
Bro, youth who makes everything so freaking difficult.
I'm gonna lose my marbles.
I'm gonna make freaking lose it.
Come on, bro.
Why aren't you working?
There it is.
Perfect.
There we go.
Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool.
She is building Gundam.
Which is very nifty.
Okay.
Yes, everybody say thank you for all the gifted.
I'm gonna go to bed.
It's about midnight.
Have a good time, y'all.
Tell Cocone to say hello and just be like...
I don't know.
I don't know what to say for a raid message.
No, don't say bunny bazongas.
No, don't do that.
Just say Madam is sleepy.
Just sleepy raid.
Because I'm going to bed.
I don't think I'll be able to stop and say hi.
Be like, Madam says hi.
She's sleepy.
But she wants to tell us to say hi.
Sleepy Madam raid.
All right.
Later, you guys.
I'll see you tomorrow.
For the hand cam stream.
I think I'm gonna get my nails done
because my nails are a little bit grown out.
What time is my stream at?
Quick, to Twitter.
Away.
I've been like totally...
Oh, did I get suspended?
Okay, stuff wasn't loading.
When that happens, I just assume I got to suspended.
Okay, it's at 4 p.m.
I like have been all over the place with my schedule
because I've been having to get stuff done
and then take care of the cats
and then like have tours and then errands and then blah blah blah.
And then I keep forgetting what time I put my streams at
and then I'll miss the time.
All right, later guys.
Yes, cat and bum.
Night night.
Sleepy Madam raid.
Bye.
Kisses for the stinkies.
Stinky indeed.